This is Jocko podcast number
one 87 with David Burke and me,
Jocko Willink. Good
evening Dave. Good evening.
And in case anyone was wondering
where Echo Charles is at this time,
echo is actually in Hawaii
trying to get back in touch with,
I know the land as we used to call
it and he will be back in a few more
episodes. In the meantime, I've got
Dave Burke here who now lives in the
AOT of San Diego, and if
you don't know about Dave,
he was on this podcast number 69 in number
one 35 he was a Marine Corps fighter
pilot through the f 18
he was a top gun pilot,
top gun instructor, top
gun, senior instructor,
F 16 pilot f 22 pilot f 35 pilot
the first and still only one of a few
pilots qualified on all those platforms.
He was the first commanding officer
of an f 35 operational squadron.
And on top of that,
he was the commander of ANGLICO salt six
on the ground with us in the battle of
Ramadi.
And he and his team did
scores of operations with u
bruiser and he is now with
us on the team at echelon front where
he leads the long range leadership
development and alignment program.
Okay.
So Dave, thanks for coming on and filling
in for echo. It's good to be here,
man.
Have you been brushing up on your video
games and eighties and nineties movies?
Unfortunately, no, I'm not gonna
be able to fill in for that check.
Well actually it's a good thing that
you do have the experience that you have
and it doesn't have very much to do with
Super Mario brothers cause I want to
talk tactics and it's
one of my, all right,
I wrote that it was one of my favorite
Marine Corps doctrinal publications.
That's, that's kind of a,
that's really a big statement
as if I sit around and grade,
which one's my favorite, but it
definitely is up. There it is.
M C D p One tack three tactics.
So let's get into it.
How long, how long were you in the Marine
Corps for Dave? 23 years. 23 years.
And you retired as what a lieutenant
colonel, 10 o'clock check.
Did you, so you went to
the basic school? I did.
Did you guys cover this in
the basic school? Absolutely.
And actually when I went to the basic
school in 1994 it was the predecessors,
basically the same pub, uh, the
one dash three at a different,
slightly different name but
pretty much the same stuff.
And I actually looked at this
one is dated July of 1997.
I looked for a, a newer one and
there isn't one. This is it. Yup.
And it's interesting cause
you'll, everyone will see
there's examples in here.
They don't have examples obviously
from Iraq and Afghanistan or Iraq too.
And then Afghanistan. I'm
sure at some point they will.
They will do that because they got
a lot of Gulf war examples and I I,
you know,
obviously they were just looking for some
recent examples when they did it in 97
that was the last big
war. So there you go.
But we'll get into it
and the book starts with a forward
and because it's the marine corps,
the Marine Corps, even when they
write a forward, it sounds good.
So this is how it starts off.
[inaudible] this publication
is about winning in combat.
Yeah.
Is there any better way to
start this manual? Nope.
This publication is about winning in
combat. Winning requires many things,
excellence in techniques and appreciation
of the enemy, exemplary leadership,
battlefield judgement
and focused combat power.
Yet these factors by themselves
do not ensure success in battle.
Many armors armies,
both winners and losers have possessed
many or all of these attributes.
When we examine closely the difference
between the differences between Victor
and vanquished, we draw one conclusion.
Success went to the army's whose leaders
senior and junior could best focus
their efforts, their skills, and
their resources toward a decisive end.
Okay.
Sounds like the Marine Corp is a saying
that leadership is the most important
thing on the battlefield.
Repeatedly. When you're at TBS,
you're there to learn to be a leader.
That is what you hear every single day.
Leadership is the difference there.
Success arose not merely from
excellence in techniques, procedures,
and material, but from their leader,
but from their leaders abilities to
uniquely and effectively combine them.
Winning and combat depends upon tactical
leaders who can think creatively and
act decisively.
So taking all of these techniques and
these procedures and the material and
being able to take those things and
mix them up and combine them together,
that is what makes, that's the
winning combination, the creativity.
How often did people at TBS
talk about being creative?
Believe it or not, they, they never
used those. They didn't say be creative.
They,
they would say think they'd give you all
these doctrine and pubs and all these
rules, but they would say,
you actually need to think and think
of what makes the most sense here.
And they bred a lot of flexibility. I
never remember anybody saying be creative,
but they said, think about
it, think of this makes sense.
And if it doesn't do something else,
and these are the rules, the guidelines.
But there was always as maneuvering
around there to bring all those pieces
together.
I say that combat is an
exercise in creativity
and people,
especially people that don't know
anything about combat or war or anything,
they always kind of, that
always surprises them, right?
Because they think creative being
creative is writing a song or painting a
picture. But for me,
being a creative is positioning your
machine gunners effectively. Yeah.
Right. I mean that's, that's
like true creativity. Yeah.
I mean the mind
leadership's not a template.
It isn't just here's what to do in
this situation. You have to think,
you have to think creatively
and come up with the best idea.
I see that in mixed martial
arts. So one of, uh,
one of my favorite mixed
martial artists of all time.
Do you know who fade or Emelianenko
is? I do. You do? I do. Okay.
I'm impressed with your knowledge.
So two things about fake door.
Number one, he was completely stoic
and never showed any emotions.
Win or lose, didn't matter.
You could look at him after a fight and
you wouldn't know if he just won the
pride GP or if he just lost his first
match in his life. He looked the same.
And so that's one very good lesson learned
from fade or the other lesson learned
from fate or is it fade or would take
the skills that he had and apply them in
very creative ways where
you'd say, oh, he just did,
you know, a judo throw
followed by a submission,
a sambos submission attempt to followed
by just dropping bombs of ground and
pound and, and those are
all three separate things.
And he would just mix them up all really
well together. And that when you see,
that's like the new level of mixed
martial arts is the older generation,
hey, I was really good at Jujitsu, or
hey, I was really good at wrestling.
Or Hey,
I was really good at striking and I would
kind of stay in my lane and if I could
bring you into my world, I could
beat you. Now it's just who has,
who can take all these tools and get
creative with them and apply them to this
scenario that they're in.
Same thing with leadership.
Same thing with combat
leadership. And by the way,
same thing with all leadership. It
doesn't only apply to combat check.
All right. Moving on. This book
pertains equally to all marine leaders.
Whether they're duties entail, combat,
service, support, combat support,
or combat arms.
All Marines face tactical decisions
in battle regardless of their role.
As tactical leaders must develop and
hone their war fighting skills through
study and practice.
This publication serves as a guide
for that professional development.
It addresses the theory of tactics
and its application in a chaotic and
uncertain environment.
The concepts and ideas
within this publication are
battle tested throughout our
history.
One of the most important reasons for
the success of the United States Marine
Corps has been the military skill of
our leaders at every level level of
command. Through their tactical
skill and battlefield judgment.
Our commanders achieve tactical and
operational advantage at the decisive time
and place, and they talk a lot
about the chaotic and environment,
which as we know, that's what combat
is. And by the way, that's what life is.
That's what businesses,
that's what the world is.
So getting into chapter
one, understanding tactics,
Huh?
Such a straight forward, the marine corps,
the Marine Corps doctrines,
doctrinal material is so
straightforward and so simply written.
It's just outstanding.
Starts off with a couple of quotes
in tactics. The most important thing
is not whether you go left or right,
but why you go left or right,
and that's when General Al Gray,
29th commandant of the Marine Corps,
41 years, three Purple Hearts,
Korea, Vietnam, a Mustang
officer by the way, get some.
He's the only one. He's the only,
he's the only commandant
that's pictured in his,
in his official picture as the commandant
of the Marine Corps in his cabinet
scam. He's absolutely
get some, he's a legend.
I think I had like a maybe a year or two
overlapped with him where I was in and
he was in,
I think he retired in like 91 or
92 or something like that and yeah,
so there you go. The most important
thing is why understanding why this is
underlying tenant, really of decentralized
command but of of all leadership.
Next one is next quotas.
There is only one principle
of war and that's this.
Hit the other fellow as quick
as you can, as hard as you can,
where it hurts him the
most when he ain't looking.
That's Sir William Slim,
who's actually a Brit
fought world war one and World War II.
What's up with fighting in World War
One and World War II? Totally mad.
It's just,
it's like we've talked about world
war one on this podcast a few times.
You and I have and did what?
A savage experience and to the roll
right back and do it again, you know,
25 years later. Yeah. Yeah. What's
up with that? Hey, yeah. You know,
you barely survived. Guess what? Go
get some more and my, the way he,
he like led the fight in Japan.
I led the fight against Japan and in
Burma. I mean that guy was no joke.
So there's the principle go hard,
go fast and when they're
not looking. All right.
Continuing on this book is
about winning in combat.
Winning requires a thorough understanding
of and knowledge of tactics.
But what is tactics?
An art and a science tactics is the art
and science of winning engagements and
battles. It includes the use
of firepower and maneuver,
the integration of different arms and
the immediate exploitation of success to
defeat the enemy as well as the
sustainment of forces during combat.
So think about that right there you
got, you got the art and science,
it includes firepower, firepower,
maneuver, covered, move, fire, maneuver,
right. Different arms,
taking all the different,
all the different assets that you
have and applying them correctly.
And then on top of that,
the immediate exploitation of
success to defeat the enemy.
So when things are going good and
you see the enemy start to crack,
it's time to go drop the hammer. Yup.
It also includes the technical
application of combat power,
which consists of those techniques and
procedures for accomplishing specific tax
within a tactical action.
So I guess they're saying technical
application of combat power.
This is like one level below tactics.
This is like you're going to
shoot correctly, you're gonna.
Yeah. And you actually have to know
how all of your equipment works.
This machine gun will,
we'll go this far and be effective
at this range and beyond that range.
You need another piece of equipment.
So you have to actually know
all these technical things.
It's no different in an airplane.
You have to have all the understanding
of how these things work.
But that by itself isn't enough. That's
where the creativity comes in and hey,
I'm going to use this machine gun to get
this reaction and they're going to move
in some other direction and then
I'm going apply other combat power.
I have to know what that power
can do and where and how it works.
And that's the art that they're talking
about is bringing all these things in
together and the good commanders
recognize they see it go.
Now it's time for this.
Not because the book says the range
because they see it as a leader.
And to apply that.
I was in the talk for the first,
the five oh six in Ramadi and their
battalion commander was just like such a
legit guy and there was a lot of mayhem
going on and he's sitting there in a
chair in the talk, just, you
know, just a normal whatever,
crappy chair and any, they're
getting questions from the field,
they want to drop like a building.
They wanted to call queue off.
There's a bunch of things going
on. And this guy, he was just an I,
one day he's going to be on
the podcast. He was just,
but I'm just watching him and this
was when I first got to her money.
I'm watching this guy and they're
going, they're going, hey sir,
they want to bring
tanks down to this area.
They got through there was even
fire and he'd like look at it,
kind of glance over at the map
and he'd be, he'd say, do it
just as calm as you could possibly be.
Pretty awesome. Yeah. That guy had some,
uh, some serious he had,
he had a good handle on the art
and the science back to the book.
Tactics were first the concepts and
methods we use to accomplish a particular
military.
I made a particular objective in either
combat or military operations other than
war in war.
Tactics is the application of combat
power to defeat the enemy and engagements
and battles.
Combat power is the total destructive
force we can bring to bear against the
enemy.
It is a unique product of a
river of a variety of physical,
moral and mental factors. C,
so this, so this is when you start
talking about leadership, right? Because,
because, okay, the physical thing
we get, we get what guns are,
we get what airplanes are, we
get what tactical maneuvers are.
But then when you start talking about the,
the moral and the mental factors and how
are you going to get a bunch of human
beings to do something that is
going to be dangerous to them.
Yeah.
Yeah. And to expect that from
a 19 year old marine. He's,
they said at the beginning,
this is leadership at every
level. Lance corporals,
fire team leaders and
expecting and demanding that
they behave morally in what's
going to be maybe the most brutal physical
situation there'll be in their lives
and recognizing that without that
you're going to lose in the long run.
It's a losing plan to be devoid of
morals in doing this. In combat,
it's pretty amazing. That's the
s the super strategic picture.
Yeah, the long game.
They realize without it in the end
we will lose if we don't have that,
if we don't have the moral
high ground. Right. Loose
tactics results in the actions and
counteractions between opposing forces.
It includes the use of maneuver supported
by the application and coordination of
fires to gain advantage in order to
defeat the enemy in military operations.
Other than war tactics may be the schemes
and methods by which we perform other
missions such as to control a crowd or
provide a secure environment for the
delivery of food medicine or supplies
to a nation or people in need.
Okay.
As stated in the definition.
I wonder if this one,
when this gets rewritten right
now, if they'll tone back,
if they won't mention as much like the
military operations other than war.
Cause that in 1997 there was a lot of,
it kind of seemed like what
the world was going to be.
Now you know it's going to be, hey look,
we might not be fighting a war
ever again, but we at least,
you know we're going to be
doing things that will require,
that's what they called
it a military first.
For those of you that are
wondering what that is,
military operations other than the war.
This is like a humanitarian
assistance mission.
This is like a security and stabilization
mission. So those kind of things,
crowd control, those kinds of things or
what they're talking about. And in the,
this was written in 97
so, and it certainly,
you certainly could have, if you
had a naive view of the world,
you certainly could have
fought yourself. You know,
all we really gonna fight another
like actual war are. We Really gonna
do that
and that it,
it's really easy to look at it
from a logical perspective and say,
lessen America's just this giant country.
We have this super military force and
technology and no one is going to step up
to the plate. Yeah. Try
and get some. Right,
so let's just focus on these other things.
Okay.
He pretty easy to think that. Yeah.
I actually remember when I got in the
Marine Corps in 94 Desert Storm was in the
rear view mirror. I kind of missed
that big hop and I remember thinking,
I wonder if I'm ever really
going to get into combat.
You and a lot of years went by before
the opportunity was there and a lot of us
thought that might ever happen in my
career. Yeah. A lot of people never did.
They spent that decade in between 91 2001
they did eight nine 10 years and they
got out and never saw anything like that.
Our newer guys that did 25 30 years came
in in 97319741975 know 1971 like if you
join,
if you got to the seal teams
in 1971 or 1972 you didn't you,
you know you didn't go to Vietnam. Yeah.
Well actually, so let's look at it.
You, if you went straight into
the seal, the seal teams, you,
you joined in 1970 it took
you, it took you, you know,
to go through bootcamp.
Next thing you know,
it's 1971 and a half and then you show
up at a seal team and now it's 1972 and
there's no, they're not deploying platoons
anymore. Yeah. So there's a couple,
there's some, some odds and
ends are still going over,
but they're not deploying straight
up platoons. Or if you're a new guy,
you don't go. And now if you didn't
do anything in the Gulf, which was,
there's a couple of platoons in the Gulf,
there was a couple platoons in Panama,
there's a couple platoons in Grenada,
there were, you know what I mean?
It's like if you weren't
one of those people,
you could easily have gone through
30 year career. Next thing you know,
you look up it's 2001 you're you, well,
it's the year 2000 and you're
retiring from 1970 to 2000 yeah.
And people sometimes forget the Gulf
War was like four days. You know, the,
the sustained combat operations, it
was like 96 hours, something like that.
And if you miss that, which a lot of
people did, that was the big show.
A an entire generation. Yeah. Yeah.
Going back to the book as the,
as stated in the definition,
tactics is a combination of art and
science to gain victory over the enemy.
Yeah.
The Art of tactics lies in how we create
creative creatively form and apply
military force in a given situation.
Okay.
I really like talking about
that creatively form and
apply military force in a
given situation. It involves
the creation, positioning,
and maneuver of combat power.
When do we flank the enemy
and when do we ambush him?
When do we attack and when
do we infiltrate? How do
we use speed and momentum?
To achieve a decisive advantage.
This creativity is developed
as a developed capacity,
acquired through education,
practice and experience.
How much more?
How much more qualified are you
right now to be on the battleground,
be on the battlefield in Ramadi in 2006
how much more qualified are you now than
you were then? The things
that I would see now,
the things that I would know to look for
now that I didn't even think of then w
and what you just said, that that, that
last comment that that's everywhere,
that, that, that training piece,
all the pieces go into that and and any
one of them without the other doesn't
work. You can't just be
awesome at one thing.
You can't just be all about
the size of these things.
And when you usually work creativity,
I mean when you see people do things
like that and it where it's like,
it's like artistry.
You see just the flow and the maneuvers
and the things that are coming in.
And I'm sure that that first, the
five or six when he said do it,
he's actually looking up and seeing
this is the reaction that I'm gonna get.
This is what's going to happen
when it happens. You know,
he's seeing those things. Uh,
and I love that image of him just
sitting there in the chair and like,
okay,
Yup, do it. And No, and knowing
what's going to happen, you know,
wellbeing beyond what,
what people can see in real
time and knowing that you
can't know what's going to
happen. For sure. I mean,
at the same time you're saying you gotta
do it and then you're thinking, okay,
I know there's a, at least an 80% chance
that this goes the way I'm thinking.
Oh, go.
And there's also a 20% chance that this
isn't something completely different
happens. And he's also totally
relinquished control of what happens next.
I mean, there's nothing he
can do once he says do it,
he's totally relinquished control of
what's gonna happen at that point with his
guys. And that's it and
the the best leaders,
they're completely comfortable doing that
because they know what their guys are
going to do because they
have trained them so hard.
They have repeated that situation so
many times that they are for all the cast
that is definitely going
to ensue. He's extremely,
he knows exactly what his guys are
going to do and how they're gonna react.
Back to the book, the Science of tactics
lies in the tactical application,
the technical application of combat power.
It includes mastering the techniques
and procedures that contribute to the
development of war fighting such
as mark marksmanship, navigation,
gunnery and close air support.
The execution of these techniques and
procedures must become second nature for
us.
This requires intensive and continuous
training without mastery of basic war
fighting skills,
artistry and creativity in their
application are impossible.
Discipline equals freedom.
You've got to have the discipline on
the little things and then you can get
creative with them.
Huh.
Now that we've examined the
art and science of tactics,
let us look at how we can use tactics
to compliment strategy and campaigning
strategy and campaign and bring our forces
to a particular place at a particular
time. We use tactics to win in combat.
A war typically involves many individual
engagements that form a continuous
fabric of activity.
War typically involves many individual
engagements that form a continuous fabric
of activity. There is
so much going on in war.
You know, when we did
our first big push into,
I guess it was cop iron and there was 50
armor pieces that were getting ready to
go and like one of them, oh look,
someone from the one three, seven
was just talking about, okay,
well here's where we're at with
fuel. And of course, you know,
we had fuel for our home views,
humvees or whatever, you know,
like we drive around, but they had 50
armor pieces that drink like diesel.
Like what do you think they get
to? I mean it's just something,
it's just something completely crazy.
Probably two miles to the gallon
or something like that. Yeah,
I think it's gallons per mile. Yeah. I
think it's that much worse that much.
Yeah. But here we were
just thinking, okay,
well the armor just going to be where
the arm is going to be and that's all
good. But they're
thinking, oh, actually no.
We need to have whatever thousands and
thousands of gallons of diesel fuels
gotta be here and it's gotta be
there and it's gotta be delivered.
It's gotta be good. And it's
coming from where it's coming from,
some totally different place and all that
stuff has to be orchestrated and boom.
And there you go. And then we're
going on this combat operation.
There's so much going on. And by
the way, convoys get hit fuel,
big fuel trucks that have 28,000 gallons,
they get hit on an ambush and they
don't even make it to Ramadi like that
happened regularly. Yup, absolutely.
And on the other side of that, when he,
that phrase, that continuous fabric,
you also have to get the
folks at your lowest level,
the folks out there with a rifle,
maybe the guys driving the tank
to recognize how everything hell,
every individual thing they do actually
affects this whole campaign and that
even those small individual actions that
seem like there's nothing else going on
in the world other than you and maybe
that that sniper on the roof for that
position,
that even your interaction with that
one thing will have implications all the
way down to the entire campaign to
the strategic level. The Marine Corps,
I don't think they say it anymore.
They used to have a phrase called the
strategic corporal with the recognition
that even this engagement,
you are influencing so many other things
at this broad level that you actually
have to be aware of your actions and
that gets back to that comment about even
the moral behavior.
Think of the Times that we saw guys do
things that we knew or were wrong and how
it totally undermined the big strategy
because everything got shifted away from
the war and they got shifted
towards whether we did
something right or wrong and
got them the news and all this [inaudible]
was the one I was talking about I
regret for sure, but a couple. So
people acting like knuckleheads. Yep.
And next thing you know that,
that that had event completely
fueled the insurgency for sure.
If that tiny tactical deputy like tiny
tactical event had massive think of how
many enemy fighters that recruited and
made our job strategically that much
harder.
Back to the book in combat,
our objective is victory
check.
Sometimes this involves the complete
destruction of an of the enemies forces.
At other times,
achieving victory may be possible by
attacking the enemies of will to fight the
Marine Corps must be equally prepared
to win during both situations.
Those in which the enemy forces must be
completely destroyed as during World War
II and those in which the complete
destruction of the enemies forces.
It may not be necessary or even desirable.
As the commanding general of the First
Marine Division in Desert Storm stated,
our focus was not on
destroying everything.
Our focus was on the Iraqi
mind and getting behind it.
He knew that the path to victory did not
lie in the total destruction of Iraqi
forces, but an undermining
their will to fight,
which they certainly did
very effectively. Yeah.
The environment. Next section.
The tactical arena is a dynamic
ever changing environment.
The complexity of this environment
makes combat chaotic and unpredictable.
Yeah.
As an example of confusion
and chaos on the battlefield,
consider the amphibious assault on
the island of Tarawa in November,
1943 during the assault, the
combination of high casualties,
lack of effective communications and
disruption of the second and eighth marine
regimens.
Landings on the assault beaches led
to a chaotic and nearly disastrous
situation. For the Second Marine Division.
Units were decimated under heavy fire.
Surviving Marines huddled together under
a coconut log seawall in inner mingled
units without effective
communications. Landing craft,
carrying reinforcements and supplies
could not make it over a core reef to the
landing beaches only through daring
leadership initiative and teamwork where
marines able to get off the beach and
annihilate the defending Japanese force.
The violence of combat only increases
the level of confusion and chaos.
Okay.
Robert Shirad,
a time in life correspondent
at [inaudible] Jima gave
testimony to this chaos in
what he called war at its worst.
Okay?
The first night on Elo Jima can only be
described as a nightmare in hell about
the beach in the morning. Lay the dead.
They had died with the
greatest possible violence.
Nowhere in the Pacific have I
seen such badly mangled bodies.
Okay.
Many were cut squarely and half legs
and arms lay 50 feet from any body.
Okay.
Battle is the collision of
opposing forces animate,
interactive and unpredictable.
Unpredictable in behavior
performance varies from week to week,
day to day and even hour to hour as a
unit interacts with its environment and
the enemy
[inaudible]
rough. I know you and I often
joke about our complete and utter.
Our experience just pails. I
mean obviously in comparison
to a, the guys that fought at Tarla,
the guys that fought at evo gene with
the guys that fought Europe in World War
II and you get in those
environments, right?
Those environments and it is this,
this idea of this dynamic and complex
and ever changing battlefield.
There it is.
Okay.
Yeah, I've said it a few times
and I still feel this way.
I'm embarrassed sometimes to call
what I did in an airplane combat.
I read these books and I listen to the
podcast and I listen to these stories and
it's almost hard for me to even try
to relate to the idea of that I was in
combat and in an airplane, you know,
given what these things sound like.
What'd you think about those king
B pilots from, from till? Yeah,
I'll, I'll, I'd love to share, swap
stories of those guys. You know, what did,
what did I do compared to
what way they did? You know,
there's a quote that I didn't read
and I don't know why I didn't,
I had it marked but I just didn't read it.
But there was like a
situation on the ground,
there was total enemy fire everywhere
and like one aircraft approached and got
shot out and the team on the
ground, this is, this was one,
it was either one or two, it's one of the,
one of the sod crews was down on the
ground and they're just trying to get
extracted
and
did basically all the pilots
are like, hey, we can't go in.
You guys need to move
to a different extract.
You need to move to different extracts.
You needed to go somewhere else.
Like we need more fires but we can't
get in there. And this one pilot,
this one can be pilot comes on and he
just comes on the mic and says, can be,
goes down, meaning, Hey, I'm
going in. Yeah, whatever.
There's enemy fire. Cool. Watch this.
So legit. I love how this
book is called tactics.
This book about tactics.
And I think that section we're on
is called understanding tactics.
And they're talking
about the chaos of war.
It's not a book, just about tactics do
this, do that. This is what worked. It's,
it's about war. And, and you
said it a couple of times,
success in combat is the only measurement
the marine corps ever given their
marines to be successful in combat.
And to remind them of just how hard that
actually is and the things that you're
going to see and smell and feel and endure
in combat is well beyond what we can
replicate in training. And
this serves as a reminder.
You know day one of you would
Jima and it gets back to,
we said it would be pretty arrogant to
think that a day like that could never
happen again in the future that we're
never going to have something like that
ever again. I had a guy,
I was working for a guy and
doing a project where were
the brief that was given
was listen we need as seals to kind
of like move in a different direction
because since we have, you
know, satellite coverage, we don't
need to do reconnaissance anymore.
And since we have t lambs we don't need
to do direct action cause we could just
send a GPS guided missile. Like,
why would you send troops
on the ground to go do that?
Like there's no reason to.
And, and this was, you know,
this was around the same time period.
This was like 96 97 and
the theory was, look,
we will not,
we as seals are not going to do
a direct action mission again.
It's just not gonna happen.
And you know, I mean I,
I was sitting there listening,
I was disappointed to hear that,
but it was hard for me to think
what could bring that about, right?
Because every scenario I could
think of was, oh, well you just,
you just send an a a t lamp.
Right? That's what you do. Okay.
Maybe I was thinking maybe like
a hostage rescue scenario. Okay.
That's the one now how often
does that happen? Right? So like,
yeah. And then you know, you
fast forward, what was it,
five or six years from
there and I was doing it,
I was doing a direct action rate almost
every night of the week in Baghdad.
And we had been for 15
years. Yes, yes, exactly.
When I got to the fleet in 1998, my first
fighter squadron combat capable squad,
when we got introduced to GPS weapons,
first squadron in the Marine
Corps to get a GPS weapon.
And the brief that I was given was
you'll never overfly the target again.
You now have a weapon that you can release
from standoff range that will guide
itself to the target. You'll
never have to overfly the target,
which meant the risk goes down. You'll
never have to be worried about smaller,
never overfly the target again. And,
and, and it was three years later,
you know,
we kicked things off and think of how
many times we had an aircraft directly
overhead in every one of those missions,
you know, exposed to the enemy. Uh,
and that complacency that came in from
technology will solve these problems for
us. What was the threat to your aircraft
when you were supporting troops on the
ground in Afghanistan? The threat was
small arms and, and shoulder fire, uh,
iron man pads, they call it, you know,
[inaudible] see short range missiles,
which the thing of it is, is that if you
get outside the three, four mile range,
there are no, there are
literally no threat at all.
But if you get inside that range,
almost anybody in the world could
pick one of those things up,
look through a little optic and shoot
it and the missile goes after the heat
signature. And they were,
they were everywhere.
I went to Stinger missile school.
Yeah. And yeah, it's, it's not,
it's not a hard weapon to know to work.
I mean the school is like a week long.
I mean it's not a long school and you go
to that school and then you can pick up
one of those things and like
you just said, I mean if,
if I pulled out the manual
right now, I could PR,
I could shoot down an
aircraft pretty easily.
And if you had spent the last 10 years
fighting against the Russians and yet you
could definitely shoot
out an American airplane.
And that's what we're dealing with is
guys that had actually a lot of experience
with it and that stuff
was everywhere. Um, yeah,
never over find the target to
your, a directly over overhead,
the target at very low altitudes because
you needed to be a little while to,
to provide the support at huge risk. Um,
look and there's certainly a balance.
Technology has allowed us to do a
whole bunch of things and that's,
that's good stuff. But Hey, we'll
never have this happen to us again.
Meaning are human beings are never going
to be put in those situations again,
it's, and I love how this manual is,
that's what it's telling the marines, hey,
read this book. Oh by the way, this
is what's happened and it's going,
we know what's going to happen again.
I don't know when or where it's going
to happen again. For sure. And you know,
you were pointing out that,
and this is, this is actually,
I'm gonna point this out later.
I think I'm going to point this out
later as a short fall to this book.
But what you're pointing out right now
is is you know it's not about do this or
do that because think about it. What have
they told you? What have they taught?
What tactics have they
talked about? So far? Zero.
They've talked about zero tactics.
What they've told you is
get ready for mayhem. Yeah.
Learn the fundamental tactics and
then get ready for total mayhem.
That's what they've told you so far.
Be Creative. That's what they've,
they've used the word creativity
like over and over again. Yeah.
That's what they're trying
to get into your heads.
They haven't even told
you any tactics yet. So,
and I think part of that reason is because
there is a fundamental baseline that
all marines have that they assume and
so they don't really talk about it in
here.
And maybe that's the reason why I pictured
it as a little bit of a shortfall of
hey, this is tactical. What you'd like.
If you've read the book
the last hundred yards,
which gets very in the weeds on tactics,
like the actual
maneuvering small elements.
And this doesn't really have it.
And I think the reason it doesn't
really have it is because of the assumed
knowledge of every marine. Yeah, for sure.
And I think to put some
context around this,
the Marine Corps knows and expects the,
the actual tactics are going to be
taught at school. At school. Yeah.
And then what the Marine Corps I think
is really trying to get the youngest
junior marines, whether it's a junior
marine leader, an officer, a lieutenant,
or or or young private,
is what tactics means.
Not the application of the tactic itself,
but what does it mean to be
part of the tactic for winning?
And it's everything from understanding
the nomenclature of your weapon to the
brutal nature of war.
And they know that what's required is
actually going to learn the tactics that
you will apply as an artilleryman or
infantry man or a supply officer or a
logistician. But tactics make no mistake,
that is the brutal application of
war. You know what this reminds me of?
So when we're, we're, we're working with,
when we are working with a
company at echelon front,
it seems like oftentimes what
people learn about business,
like let's say they get their
MBA from somewhere or they are,
even if they've gone through some kind
of a program, whatever kind of program,
what they learn is actually the
maneuvering on the battlefield.
Like they learn how to, they
learn that technical part of it.
And the part that they don't
often know is all this, oh,
there's going to be complete
and total mayhem. Yeah.
Like things that you had no
idea what w oh by the way,
old leadership, what you need to do is
surround yourself with some good people.
Okay. And by the way,
half those good people are going to be
crazy and the other half are going to be
insane. Yeah. Right. Like every,
every like that's what's missing.
So what they focus on here is kind
of what we focus on at echelon front,
working with companies. Oh.
Like there's going to be things
that aren't going the way you,
the way they were gonna be going on
paper when you made that hire or when you
opened that branch or whatever
you did. It's interesting. No,
I think it's exactly the same for
sure. Check. Going back to the book,
military forces are complex systems
consisting of individuals and equipment.
They interact internally and externally
in seemingly chaotic ways as clouds that
we, it's wrote,
a battalion is made up of individuals
the least important of whom may chance to
delay things or make them go wrong.
That's what I was just saying like that
that sentence is the least important
person. Yes. Can literally
destroy your plan. Yes. Yeah.
As Marines, we believe in,
we believe the actions of
single individuals can have
great impact in combat and
can also make things
go right. For example,
Sergeant John Basilone as a machine
gunner at Guadalcanal contributed,
and this is a quote in large measure to
the virtual annihilation of a Japanese
regiment.
Yeah.
He steadfastly manned his position in
the face of repeated wave type of salts
and was instrumental in breaking the
enemy's ability to press the attack,
forcing them to retreat
without achieving their goals.
Medal of honor for that situation.
Navy cross later where when he was
killed at [inaudible] but virtual
annihilation of a Japanese regiment
Bazi yeah. The legend
battle is also influenced by a
variety of external conditions.
Okay.
Directions and missions established
by authorities, terrain,
whether attitudes of the civilian
populace that often cannot be foreseen.
The outcome of combat can only be
anticipated in terms of probabilities.
All those things, authorities to reign.
Whether attitudes of this really
terrain you're looking at,
you're looking at a map,
a one to 50,000 map or even a one
to 24 map, which is twice as good.
Sometimes that terrain doesn't even
reflect anything that you've seen that you
thought it was going to look like.
Yeah. The people that, that part of the,
the people, I mean, that's
the, to think about that.
I'd like you to consider the attitudes
of the people in the application of this
plan and like the amount of chaos is
embedded just in that comment. Yeah. Uh,
it's, it's, it's
staggering. And then again,
relinquish control of your people and
have them go deal with that as it happens
in real time. Yeah. We were
going to send you into a city
that's,
that's been under a regime that's
now got an insurgence in there.
There's people getting killed.
They're trying to survive.
They're from a totally different culture.
Consider that and just, you know,
plan around Matt. You just had that as
one of the factors and the weather too.
So yeah. And that happens in
the business world too. Totally.
You get things completely wrong. Get
things completely wrong. Oh, this will,
I'm sure everyone's going to love
this new product we're making. No,
no one likes it. Doesn't sell anything.
Or I was working with a company and
they made something and they anticipated
selling between two and four per shop,
that they were going into
a massive spread of shops,
a very large chain of shops.
And they made this something they were
anticipating selling between two and four
per shop.
They ended up selling on
average 34 per shop per day.
Yeah. It like crazy. Yeah.
Who predicted that no one then they're
spending $20 million on a new factory
immediately check
back to the book. Technology also
affects the tactical environment,
but not always. As anticipated,
technology may reduce uncertainty
and it may also increase it.
The Spartans organized into Phalanxes
attacked and close formation,
making it easy to see
and control one's forces.
Today tactical formations are less well
defined as distances between elements of
increased complicating command
and control in increased weapons.
Lethality communications range and tackle
mobility causes us to disperse forces
over greater distances,
wars more fluid as a result of technology
while the machine gun bogged down
warfare and world war one.
Tactical innovations like the tank,
the airplane and the aircraft carrier
made warfare more rapid and free flowing
in World War II. So that's,
that's what you just talked
about with technology.
The the GPS guided bomb. Yeah.
And as a pilot I was on pretty much on
the leading edge of tactical evolution
in, in, in aviation. And it was,
it was awesome. There were some,
what did you guys start
flying? Night Vision Goggles.
So I have a very similar story to you.
I had my first night vision goggle flight
in the summer of 1998 and they were
pretty new at the time. And
I so get this, I go on my,
we do like a simulator
dual brief. I learned how
it works in a, in like a
dark room and everything,
but you can't replicate it till you get
in an airplane and the first airplane
you have an instructor in the
back. We get in the airplane,
go do the whole thing. We
get airborne, we're out here.
Southern California I've taught,
took off out of at an El Toro before
it closed just over the water.
And I'm looking up and I'm looking to all
the airplanes at lax lined up hundreds
of miles away.
And I can see this with my night vision
goggles and I ask the instructor, Hey,
is this, is this pretty
common? He's like, well,
I can't actually see what you're
looking at. S said, how come he says,
I'm not wearing my goggles? And
this was a kind of a really old,
really kind of senior crusty guy if I
think it was originally an ace six pow,
the transition. He goes, I don't like him.
And I remember I was a really
young student at times.
I certainly wasn't going to have, I'm
just, you know, Roger that and go to that.
It didn't really occur to me until
years later talking, you know,
conversation we had about when the seals
were trying to introduce goggles and
guys like, hey, we don't need
that kind of stuff. Yeah.
And just thinking how
being in it. And I'm like,
that is the most insane thing
I've ever heard. But, but,
but just something to think
about. I have been on flights.
It happened actually twice,
once in a combat mission in Afghanistan
where my wingman took off and he didn't
have his bracket.
He forgot his bracket that attached to
the helmet where you put the goggles on.
So he reached down, uh,
to get the night vision goggles to mount
him on his helmet airborne. He's like,
dude, I don't have my bracket weight,
which means there's no goggles period.
So we're going to go
do seven hours without,
without him having night vision goggles.
And he was kind of paralyzed by that.
Oh yeah, I'll just like Frankie. Yeah.
So he had put himself in this technology
and then the moment that technology
technological thing he'd been asked
to cooked custom to was gone. He,
he didn't know what to do and
was like, hey man, we're good.
We'll put in a couple of risk mitigators.
We'll just some out to Delta and will.
A couple of very easy things we could do,
but it was hard for him and that
the technology ended up itself,
doesn't solve your problems unless you
can a know how to use it and react to
when it's not giving you
what you want. And um,
I've seen that in airplanes all the time,
that all of a sudden gps gps goes down
in an airplane and what you want to do is
say, hey, let's just go home.
Like, we can't go home, we're,
we're here to support it.
And I've seen guys get paralyzed by losing
that technological thing that they've
become accustomed to.
And that's kind of the beauty of
what this is saying here is hey,
there's a basic thing that's going to
go on here that you have to be able to
execute.
They can't replicate the invasion of
Tarla being pinned down and watching a
regiment get decimated.
You can't replicate that in combat
and you can't replicate telling a guy,
get up in a hail of gunfire and
lead your men, but you can actually,
you can actually get people to recognize
that that's what you need to do in
those situations. And that's why those
marines actually got up and did that. Um,
there's, the contrast is incredible.
The dichotomy of that is
incredible to think about.
They're the technology
thing. The GPS, you know,
like there wasn't gps when
I first got in. There was,
but it wasn't a feasible thing to use
because it was slow and it just didn't
work. And I remember getting
told, Hey, we, with this piece
of equipment, we, we can know exactly
where we are and it weighed 28 pounds.
And I said, hey, I know exactly where I
am and I have a map and compass. Yeah,
so next question, let's move on. And, and,
and there's definitely are guys
that have become reliant on gps.
They do not know how to do land Nav.
Atlanta Nav is an absolutely critical
skill. If you know land have,
you don't need to look at your gps.
And in fact if you know it well,
you don't even need to
look at your map, right?
You remember the terrain features,
you're keeping track of your pace
and you know exactly where you are.
I didn't use a gps or a map in Ramadi
after the second week inside the city,
except on very rare occasions.
But every spirit Jolie,
I knew where I was because, well we did
it all the time. But that was actually,
if I had to say, hang on one second,
let me Orient Myself to this city.
It's over. She's like, let me break
out my gps and see where we are.
So those fundamental skills are actually
required to be able to take advantage
of the technology. When I looked
back at my first deployment to Iraq,
once we were in Ramadi for like a month,
I realized because my first appointment
we'd be going all over the place.
You know, we did a lot of work in
Baghdad, but Baghdad is huge. Right?
And we wouldn't do the same
neighborhood even, you know,
maybe we do the same neighborhood one or
two times, but most of the time I was,
hey, we just never been here before.
And I realized how much better
I should have known the,
the terrain. Like I would be looking
at the battle map going into,
on my first deployment, we'd be going
into some random town and I'd be like,
okay, here's a major landmark.
There's a mosque over here, there's a,
there's a a bridge over here.
Cool. I got that. Oh yeah,
this building looks pretty particular.
Our target building is right
next to that building. So, okay.
So I'd kind of have that
level of familiarization,
but I wouldn't know it
like what we knew when,
when in Ramadi where you're looking at
the same thing all the time and that's
how you should know the train.
That's how you should study the trade and
then when something doesn't fit in the
way it is, the way you, the way it's
supposed to, then you will recognize it.
Like if you're looking at
a in a rural environment,
because rural environments
I think are tougher to read,
I guess clearly they are tougher
to read than city environments.
Although you can get turned
around in the city as well,
but you know a stream or
a, you know, you, you, you,
you hit a little stream that wasn't on
the map and you think you were at the big
one and blah, blah blah blah.
You can just get brushed up.
But if you are tracking it, then you can,
you can make sense of it
if you've studied it more.
So be careful of completely
relying on technology.
It can is not always your
friend back to the book.
Future battles likely to
become even more chaotic? Well,
they'll combat in operation.
Desert Storm was between fairly well
defined forces in well-defined space.
The forces and operating areas in Vietnam,
Somalia and Greneda were
far less well defined.
Enemy units were dispersed and often
hidden with within the civilian population
making them hard, hard to
detect and harder to target.
They converge at a time and
place of their choosing.
Future opponents may choose to fight in
this manner to offset our overwhelming
superiority and firepower.
Little foreshadow,
yes, they may choose to fight that way.
[inaudible]
continuing on this chaotic
environment also brings opportunity.
Klaus Ritz wrote about combat.
No other human activity is so
continuously bound up with chance.
The challenge is to recognize opportunity
when it occurs in the midst of chaos
and uncertainty and to
seize it to obtain a clear,
unambiguous victory when
viewed through time.
Even the most chaotic of systems may
reveal recurring patterns that may look
that may then be exploited.
The experienced tactician will look for
these reoccurring patterns that can be
exploited to advantage. I mean,
when is that not true? That
statement and, and that,
and that's combat in a
nutshell, but I mean,
I talk about the Ooda loop all
the time in aviation and, and,
and in business too,
when you see the people,
when you're working with folks and
it's their first time, maybe they,
they've gotten, uh, their, their
first team and, uh, you know,
they introduce themselves in
the first couple of weeks and,
and very immediately,
things don't go the way that they want
and they're on their heels and they don't
know how to react. And it's not
because they're a bad leader.
It's not because they don't possess
it's, they'd never seen it before.
And if you never seen it before, a lot
of times you don't know what to do.
So you, you freeze or you do or you do
nothing or you make the wrong decision.
But it's really that sense of being
overwhelmed and right next to might be
someone that they're doing it for
10, 15 years, I'm okay, hey man,
I've seen this a thousand times and they
react them completely differently. Eh,
I've never seen a place
where that isn't true.
I mean that experience of doing things
over and over again to find a pattern go,
this is how I think this is going to
work out. That's what lets you go do it.
Because you can anticipate what that
outcome is going to be because you've seen
it so many times. Yeah, and there's,
there is a way of looking at things and
overlaying your knowledge that allows
you to see things that other people don't
see and it's hard to do and not many
people do it. Not many
people take what their,
the knowledge that they have and overlay
it onto what they're looking at and you
can't,
what you can't do is you can't let what
you're overlaying block what's behind
it. You have to overlay it.
It has to be transparent because you
have to be able to see through it.
You have to be able to see the changes,
but if you can take your experience and
you can overlay it onto what's happening
onto what's happening, it gives
you this massive advantage.
It's a huge advantage.
We talk about when flying having a
mental Rolodex of literally a billion
different,
almost like screen captures of what
you're seeing out your windscreen in your
world that you're looking at as a pilot
and having however much experience you
have back there in your head
to go. I've seen that before.
I can pull from my memory
or my recollection of things
I've thought about kind
of overlay that just like you said and
look through it almost transparently and
go,
these are the same and it
doesn't guarantee that you
know exactly what's gonna
happen next and put it narrows down to
such a small margin of what the likely
outcomes are going to be that your,
that's how you start thinking
ahead of your opponent or,
or the person even next to you is being
able to pull that experience and say
that I've seen this and I think this is
what's going to happen because of all
these other things. But just like you
said too, you don't get to freeze time.
You don't, there's no pause button.
Their airplanes are moving hundreds
of miles an hour and dynamically.
And the guys that do that really
well pull those pictures out and go,
I've seen this and they're making
moves. And you looking at how,
how did you know to do that? And
it's exactly what you just described.
I was at,
at the training command and I was
running training and we got tasked with
training the guys in a new
mission. And so we get,
we tasked the guys with this new mission
and they come up with a plan to execute
this new mission. And so when,
whenever we were taking the guys
on a field training exercise,
they would give the brief to their task
unit or their troop or their platoon and
you know, US training cadre
would sit there and we'd look,
take notes and say like, hey
this is a bad part of the plan.
Hey you should've thought about this.
Hey this won't really work. You know,
so we, we'd give them critiques
and then, and you know,
I would go last, you know what I mean?
Cause I was the guy in charge. So they,
they let me go last. So
everyone kind of, you know,
there'd be two or three guys that would
kind of pick apart the plan and then I
would go and mentioned maybe, you
know, four or five other things, right?
Because my guys would cover most of
them. So these guys get up and they're,
they brief this new mission and how
they're gonna execute this new mission.
And they go, okay, you know, we're done.
They wrap up their mission and now we
got the leadership in there to debrief
them on their, on their brief.
And my guys like didn't have anything.
And so they get to me and I was like,
okay, here's what's going on. Boom, boom.
And I just rattled off
like 19 things and the,
the senior enlisted guy that was there,
we got done and we walked out
and he was like, when you leave,
no one's going to be able to do this.
And, and I was like, no man, he's just,
but when I think about what just
occurred, what occurred during that time,
all I was doing was taking
what I knew already.
What would my senior listing I
knew as well. I just overlayed it.
He didn't ovulate it. It didn't look
the same. So he wasn't quite sure.
So I just overlayed what I
knew and said, oh yeah, here's,
here's what doesn't make sense. Cause
guess what? Cover moves still applies.
Decentralized command still
applies. We want to keep it simple.
That still applies.
Prioritize and execute.
So applies who w that's those things.
The terrain taking advantage of
the train that still applies.
So even though the mission
has a totally different name,
the fundamental principles
don't, don't change.
So if you can take an overlay what
you know you're going to do well,
and that's actually, that's actually
what good leaders do. What good leaders,
they take, what they
know about humans. Oh,
I've worked with a guy like that
before. You know what's funny?
We do our role playing people.
And one of the characters that we talk
about in our role play at echelon front,
one of the characters that we
talk about is a grumpy old Arnold,
right?
Grumpy old Arnold who's been doing this
for 25 years and he's really good and
he's really respected and, and
he likes to do things his way
and he doesn't like, you know, he
doesn't like being told what to do.
And when we, whenever we bring
up this character that I made up,
but of course like I made
it up, but everybody says,
oh well does this based on,
on my computer. Yeah. So
everybody has an Arnold.
And then we go to the next role play.
And the next role play is, you know,
this guy who's, you know, young
buck and what's young buck like?
Young buck is super fired up and
he's just ready to go get after it.
But he also doesn't like following what
the rules are because the rules are
impeding his progress and
everyone goes, oh yeah,
we got young buck over here where
it would actually say it's so funny.
Like at the muster we'll walk around
with people that go, this is yes,
here's our no there we all, you know
it's always funny. It's always good.
But what good leaders do is they,
they take now, now when someone says,
hey this is Arnold, or hey we
have an Arnold. I don't know,
it's not exactly the same.
But you can certainly overlay some of
the knowledge that you have onto that
person. You can't overlay it
completely cause that's a mistake.
As a leader it's a mistake
to treat Arnold. This Arnold
the same as that Arnold.
Cause they have the same, some similar
characteristics but they're not the same.
And what you did with this one won't work.
May Not necessarily work with that when
you're going to have to modulate it a
little bit. And so what you do
as a leader, if you can take,
and you can overlay your knowledge onto
situations that you haven't seen before,
but you recognize what
similarities there are and how to,
how to handle those scenarios that's
going to make you infinitely better. Nope,
totally. And the thousands of
flights that I had in my career,
no two are exactly the same. I never
had two flights are exactly the same.
And that's with any insert, any
job, anything we've ever done,
nothing is exactly the same. And I had,
I've had that same experience of people
saying this is that guy that you're
just, this is our Arnold or this is
our, our young buck. Um, but if you,
if as a leader you start getting
more and more successful,
you kind of racking up wins and you start
to figure that out and you think that,
you know how everything is going to play
out, that that's a killer too. And um,
we, we had, in aviation we
have, we track mishap rates,
which obviously has expensive airplanes
and airplanes crashes, catastrophic.
And there's two spikes in a
person's career. The mishap rates.
And one is about the
200 to 300 hour range,
which is we're literally just
learning how to fly an airplane.
So it stands a reason a lot of people
crash airplanes when they're first
learning how to fly. And
then after about 500 hours,
that mishap rate falls really
low and then does it very,
very low mishap rate. And then,
and then it spikes again and it
spikes at about the 2000 hour mark.
And that's a really experienced
squad commander kind of level,
really experienced. And it's because
they fall into that trap as they,
I've seen it all. And the reality is
that some of those things never change.
Actually the principles,
they never change.
But the outcomes are always
moving around. And that book,
the tiered is different than buck over
there. And when you get complacent,
think I've got this figured out.
It's same thing happens in aviation.
That's where the mishaps go up again.
And it's the same thing for a leader is
recognizing that all of these problems
are different. All of these
problems are the same.
But you do not know the outcome.
You do not know the outcome, Eh,
that's, that's that. That
is like a fire in my brain.
Every problem that I look at,
I'm simultaneously looking at it.
At the same time I'm saying, okay,
I think I've seen this before.
I also have a louder voice in my head
that's saying you don't actually know.
You don't actually know anything. You
should actually just be quiet yet.
Listen and try and figure this
thing out because you don't know.
So that's definitely right and you can
see when people get to that 2000 hour
mark,
they start to think they've got it all
figured out and that's not going to be
good. Overlay your knowledge.
Next section is called how we
view combat and how we fight.
Oh,
how we view combat,
how we view the combat environment in
large part determines how we operate in
it. There are two
competing views of combat.
Some see it in simple terms as if the
battle and the environment represented a
closed mechanical system.
This deterministic view argues
that combat is predictable.
Among the advocates of this view are
military theorists who seek prescriptive
rules for battle and analyst who predict
battle outcomes based upon force ratio.
The other view is that combat is
chaotic and uncertain in this problem.
In this probabilistic view battle is
seen as complex a complex phenomenon in
which participants interact with one
another and respond and adapt to their
environment. The probabilistic viewpoint
sees combat, it's unpredictable.
The distinctions between these
two views of combat are important.
They drive the choices
commanders make in combat.
Okay,
so this is again, I was with a client,
a new client the other day echelon front
and meeting the CEO for the first time
and it was interesting.
He was asking me in a very
okay
positive way and not a negative way.
He was asking me in a very curious way.
Basically the question was like,
like what do you teach? What
are you, what are you teaching that that,
that other people don't teach? What is it?
How, how, you know,
there's this high demand signal at my
company for you to be here and I get it
and that's why you're here
and I appreciate it, but well,
what are you talking about? Like what can
I expect to see and you don't. I said,
and I ended up going and doing the
kind of the introduction to the laws of
combat and extreme ownership.
So he, that's when he kind of,
when I got done with that, he said, oh,
I think this is what people,
from a leadership perspective,
if you have a deterministic
viewpoint of leadership,
hey, when the person does this, Oh,
here's the prescription for that. Yeah,
it doesn't work. It doesn't work. And yet
that's an easier thing to sell, right?
If I'm trying to sell you my leadership
instruction, the easiest thing, reason,
well, what problems do you have? Okay,
well I'll just tell you
what the prescription for
that type of problem is the
problem. The problem of that
is it's a lie. It doesn't true.
It doesn't work at all.
We've been working with companies for
the last couple of years and one of the
things that a lot of companies are
dealing with is growth. Economy is good.
Everybody's dealing with growth and and I,
you can see the difference in the leaders
that have these two different points
of view and the ones that think they have,
they kind of have it all figured out.
This prescriptive mindset,
there's nothing in them that feels like
they need to push and relinquish control
down in the organization because they
think they have the template and they
might've small started small and they
believe that they can control everything.
It's a very, it's centralized. It's
just, it's at their core. They, they've,
they are the leader and they did control
things when there was 27 people and
they saw them every day and they can try,
hey, everything worked awesome. Yeah,
it's really, you can do that with a
small group, especially at the beginning.
It's actually not that hard to kind
of control 1520 people and as the,
as it grows,
it's those leaders that
think that everything is
predetermined by this matrix,
this if this then that,
that that whole approach,
they're the ones that are struggling the
most and ironically you don't see it in
the beginning but the
ones that are willing to
decentralize everything and give
those the ones that actually don't have
nearly as much problem with the growth,
not because they know
it's all figured out.
It's because they know that there's no
way I can figure this out and I can't
solve any of these problems by myself
and the best thing they can do is get
their folks that when you have a
problem and here are some guidelines,
here's some things we do,
here are some foundational things
that we do at this company,
but I actually don't have the
answer for you. As a matter of fact,
I am not as good as you are at knowing
this particular situation because you're
living in it and every day I'm
off over here to do other things.
The leaders that recognize that everything
is chaotic. Nothing is predetermined,
no matter how good or
experienced they are.
They're the ones that are
the most successful and the
ones that think it's all
figured out,
they try to control everything and
they're the ones that are most likely to
fail. And from the outside, when
you walk in, you look and go,
oh, all you have to do is let them,
let this person make that decision
on their own and it's going work out.
And if it doesn't, he'll
learn from it and we'll
figure out the next time. A,
it's easy to see from the outside.
You see these two different leaders.
It's not just competence, it's everywhere.
When you sit and approach absolutely
everywhere, it's absolutely everywhere.
Prescriptive leadership, I'm putting
that one in my, uh, in my notebook.
We're not selling prescriptions.
[inaudible] health leadership, health
continue on.
The deterministic view of combat often
leads to centralized control. Hmm.
It can be a recipe for micromanagement.
Stifling the initiative.
Subordinates need to deal with
combat, inevitable uncertainties,
overly prescriptive orders and plans
inhibit a unit's ability to cope with
uncertainty and change.
Eventually the unit inflexible and unable
to adapt may be overwhelmed by events
and I'll change that. Maybe overwhelmed
to will. How's that for deterministic?
If you have that, if you
have that micromanagement,
you will end up in a bad situation.
The probabilistic view
of combat recognizes that the complexity
and uncertainty of war leads to a more
decentralized approach to control.
We placed greater trust in subordinates
to achieve the desired result.
Through the use of mission
orders and commanders intent,
subordinates are able to handle unforeseen
situations and exploit opportunities
that arise.
Marine Corps tactics are based on
the probabilistic view of combat.
Must be shocking for some people
to hear that. Yeah, I bet too.
They have a totally different viewpoint
that that did. They just think, oh,
the what you're doing. You're in
charge that day. Boston. Yeah.
Come in and tell everyone what to do.
We must be able to cope with uncertainty
and operate in an everchanging combat
environment. We must be flexible and
responsive to changes in the situation.
There are no fixed rules that can be
applied automatically and every situation
is different. That's so legit.
Picture that scene you described of being
in Tarla and all those years and look
around, your squad leaders gone,
your fire team isn't there anymore.
Your battalion commanders gone.
None of the things that you
anticipated or prepared or trained for,
they don't even exist anymore.
They're not even there.
What are you going to do now when
in this predetermined preordained,
coordinated plan? It
doesn't work. Yeah. Yeah.
That is the, the, the,
the things that you
expected are literally gone.
Your plan is, is completely evaporated.
It is nothing. Yeah.
The plan that you had is
completely and utterly gone.
And if you don't do anything
about that, you will be too. Yeah.
Very soon.
There are no fixed rules
as one tactics manual, put it
more than a half century ago.
The leader who frantically strives to
remember what someone else did in some
slightly similar situation has already
his feet on a well traveled road to ruin.
Yeah.
And that's actually from the book
and for in battle. So this is,
so this is where you have to,
this is why that overlay that you put,
it's the camp block, what you see.
It's an overlay. And for
those of you who don't know,
speaking of speaking of
just going old school, yeah.
In the old days when we used to have
maps and not these incredibly advanced
software programs that put overlay,
they're still called overlays,
but you'd put a transparent,
what was that piece of plastic
vein or something like that,
like of transparency and you would draw
little things on it and you'd say, okay,
this is, here's the terrain, here's
where the target's going to be,
and you could put another
overlay that showed the enemy,
suspected any musicians,
and he put another overlay that
showed your friendly positions.
So that's what I'm talking about. You
can see through it if you block it out.
That's not gonna work.
Leaders must remember that there are no
fixed rules and no precise checklists,
but there are bounds here.
We get in the dichotomy.
That is why successful leaders study,
train and exercise their minds
to improve tactical proficiency.
We study examples of successes and
failures not to emulate someone else's
scheme, but to increase our own
tactical understanding and competence.
Why do we do that? Why
do we, why do we study?
Yeah.
Train and exercise.
It's so that we can put those
overlays in our mind and then we can,
we can increase our own tackle.
Understanding and competence.
Okay.
Next section. Marine Corps tactics.
The successful execution of Marine
Corps tactics hinges on the thoughtful
application of a number of tactical
concepts so as to achieve success on the
battlefield. Key among these
concepts are achieving a decision,
gaining advantage, being
faster, adapting, cooperating,
and exploiting success.
Each of these concepts is discussed
in detail later in this publication.
Creative and practical employment of
these ideas throughout the planning and
execution of tactics leads to
success. Creative is number one.
That's going first.
Yeah. That's going first.
Creative and practical employment of
these ideas throughout the planning and
execution of these
tactics leads to success.
These concepts are not standalone ideas
but are to be combined so as to achieve
an effect that is greater
than their separate.
Some part of the art and science of
tactics lies in knowing where and when to
apply these concepts and which
combinations to use to achieve the desired
effect. How often does somebody
asks you what, what, what,
what law of combat do you think is most
important for us from right for us?
And it's like, well, this one's
really important, but guess what?
You can't get one without the other.
Right? They're all woven together.
The number one definition
of these concepts,
the number and definition of these combat
concepts are not fixed and their order
of presentation does not
indicate their value.
Marines may find in their studies new
or slightly different ideas that may be
just as important.
These ideas are presented
in this publication so that
readers will think about
how to achieve success on the battlefield.
Okay.
I wonder if the marines at
the basic school when you
went through were afraid to
use the word creative. I guarantee
you I guarantee kissed the,
because the word I'm
telling you, they use they,
they said think for sure and
that's what they meant to be.
They meant to be creative and yeah,
we'll find the word is the word,
but that's exactly what they're getting
at is the answer isn't in this book.
The answer isn't that we're going to go
do one week of combat and the defense
and all of a sudden you've
got all the life experience.
You need to be defensive
and you have to think
these concepts help to provide a framework
for developing a tactical mindset
that has long been the hallmark of marine
leaders from corporal through general.
Okay,
and here's the conclusion to tactics.
Tactical excellence is the
hallmark of a Marine Corps leader.
We fight in winning combat through our
mastery of both the art and science of
tactics. The Art of tactics
involves the creative.
Okay.
Once again, and innovative, once again,
use of maneuver warfare concepts.
While the science of tactics requires
skill and basic war fighting techniques
and procedures. For sure. Yeah, because
let's face it, if you don't have the,
if you don't know the techniques,
you can't apply them creatively.
You don't even know one. That's right.
It is our responsibility as marine leaders
to work continuously to develop our
own tactical proficiency
and that of our marines.
Understanding the concepts presented in
this publication provides a foundation
for that development.
Boom.
Chapter two. That was one
chapter two by the way,
that's one chapter g awesome and
we're staring at it over an hour.
That's awesome. Some chapter
two achieving a decision.
It follows then that the leader
who would, and this is a quote,
it follows then that the leader who
would become a competent tactician must
first close his mind to the alluring
formula that well meaning people offer in
the name of victory.
Okay.
To master his difficult art, he must
learn to cut to the heart of a situation,
recognize its decisive elements
and basis course of action on these
and that once again, that's
from this book, infantry battle,
which infantry battle is an awesome
book and what's really interesting about
infantry and battle, and I'm going to
cover it on the podcast probably in,
I don't know, I've got it in the queue,
but what's interesting about infantry
and battle the book is it was written in
1939 or it came out in
1939 so it's not based on,
it's not based on what we
learned in World War II.
It's what we did in World War II.
It's based on world war one
and like these things worked.
These things didn't work and they don't,
they don't. They don't say it that way,
but that's basically what it is.
It's a great book and there's some,
and this is when you see a,
when you see a leader do this,
caught to the heart of a situation,
recognize its decisive elements and
basis course of action on these.
That's like the most
pleasurable thing to see as a,
as an observer or as a trooper.
When you see someone go, hey,
here's what's going on. This
is what we're going to do.
A lot of people will be talking and all
of a sudden the leader will go, hey,
this is what's happening. This is what
we're going to do. And you go, oh,
thank God for this guy
going on another quote.
Okay.
We must be ruthlessly opportunistic,
actively seeking out signs of weakness
against which we will direct all
available combat power when the decisive
opportunity arrived and we must exploit
it fully and aggressively committing
every ounce of combat power we can muster
and pushing ourselves to
the limits of exhaustion,
which is the way you should actually
live your life as well. No big deal.
That's from, that's from FM FM one.
Yeah.
Warfighting which I don't know when
I covered that on this podcast,
but it was like podcast five
or something like that. So yes,
ruthlessly opportunistic.
Okay.
Fully and aggressively.
That's what I'm talking about.
And also recognizing that the number
of times you're going to get that
opportunity to exploit something to
win it might be once in a battle.
Yeah. It might be once and that
window may last four minutes.
It may last an hour, it may last
a day, but it might be gone. Yeah.
And when you see it,
you're gonna have to step and you're
gonna have to make that decision and
there's going to be risk in that decision.
And you're not guaranteed and
outcome in any way, shape or form.
But here's the counterpoint.
If you don't maneuver well,
that opportunity can be lost.
Yeah. And there, this is a,
there's a huge discussion about the
dichotomy. I don't use the word dichotomy,
but they, they definitely
talk about it all the time.
Just because we're saying you've gotta
be opportunities to can take advantage of
those things.
That doesn't mean that you just run to
your death doesn't mean to charge into
every bunker that you see because you
think it's the decisive bunker. No,
we talk about this all the time.
He, you even think, you know, the,
the dichotomy that comes to mind here,
the idea of being brave
and not foolhardy. Yeah.
And then you even talked about it in Q
and a recently about recognizing that
being default aggressive. Obviously
that's a really good thing, but,
but you can't be like that all the time
because if you're over aggressive and
you've explained the wrong opportunity
or you or you're actually so aggressive
that you haven't had a chance to bring
all your forces to bear when it actually
is most effective.
That's everybody as destructive as
being so disconnected or being so
unaggressive that you missed those
opportunities as well and the answer,
like you said, it always it's,
it's in that middle and
just saying be aggressive.
That doesn't solve your problems. You
actually have to know when to do that.
I remember that the podcast I was talking
about when I started thinking about
the dichotomy of leadership,
this was a big deal because,
because what I had to do
to to come up with that,
to allow my brain to get around that,
I had to say that I was
rubbing into your wrong, yeah,
that I was wrong like this.
This isn't right all the time.
It's not always good to be aggressive.
It's not always good to go forward.
It's like all those things.
It's not always good to step up and lead
all the time. No, actually it's not.
There's some times when you should
follow like for me to sit there and I
remember it was one of those situations,
this is what we just talked about.
There was some time when I was watching
something unfold and the the thought
was, well they should have been
more aggressive. And I was like,
that's what I want to say. Cause
that's what big tough Jocko says.
But guess what? That's not the right
answer. The right answer is actually,
that would have been the
wrong time to be aggressive.
And they actually did a good job by
sitting back and letting that situation
develop. So what is this? And I
was thinking about this in my head,
you know what is going on here? Oh,
because you can't be too aggressive.
You can't be aggressive all
the time. Oh and by the way,
there's every trait that you look
at. Yeah, there's a counter to it.
If you go too far with any of
them, you're wrong for sure.
And that's why the things that we teach,
we don't teach the answers of saying,
oh, your answers be default aggressive,
that that by itself doesn't work.
So you actually have to
understand not just what it means,
but when to do that and know that there
is actually an un limit to doing that,
that it will become ineffective
if you're just, I'm aggressive.
That's how I lead get on board.
And that you lead your team to, to,
to destruction because you're thinking,
I got to be aggressive. And like,
yes you do. But you have to actually
have to know when to be aggressive.
And actually sometimes the best thing
is to be the exact opposite of that and
let the situation unfold until
you see that opportunity. Yeah,
and I mean did it's flanking, right?
Flanking is an aggressive movement,
but it's not as aggressive as charging
up the middle. Right? Right, right.
The frontal assault, frontal
assault is more aggressive. It,
I'll give you credit, but it's not
going to work out better. That's right.
And then the other funny thing
from a leadership perspective is,
Hey, am I,
am I being weak? Am I
being fearful if I don't,
if I'm not aggressive.
But here's the answer and this is a
real simple way to look at it. When you,
when you deal with another human being,
are you building the relationship
or are you breaking it? Are you,
are you moving it forward or
you're moving it back? Yeah,
that's the question and, and
the answer is the answer.
The answer is if you're,
if what if I'm going to
have a conversation with you
and it's going to move our
relationship forward? Cool.
That's probably the right answer.
If I'm going to have a conversation
with you and it's going to move our
relationship backwards, that's
probably not the right answer.
So we for for sure, eve,
if you d came up with a bad plan
and my approach with you on that is,
hey Dave, your plan sucked and I
don't think you're cut out for this.
Yeah.
Or Hey, your plan socks in. I don't, I'm
going to, you have to use my plan now.
Which both of those have a
negative outcome? Both of those.
You're looking at me going, okay,
so Jocko doesn't trust me. He did.
He doesn't think my plan is any
good. Instead of me going, hey man,
can you explain to me,
I want to understand like how you're
going to execute this thing because it's
important for me to understand what
you're thinking so I can give you the
support that you need. W W can you,
can you kind of walk me through your,
your thought process and how this
is going to go down? Well, that,
what does that do with our relationship?
Now you're going to
explain something to me.
I'm going to subtly and smoothly point
out the little mistakes in the plan that
you had and I'm going to actually
let you come to the conclusion.
You're the one that's going to be
telling me that you know what has thought
about, I'm actually gonna change this
a little bit. And then I go, oh wow.
I would have never caught that. And Boom,
all of a sudden our relationship
got stronger. So yes,
there's a dichotomy. There
is, and there's actually,
there actually is a time sometimes
that the frontal assault does work.
That's why there's a frontal assault.
Absolutely. If it never worked,
it wouldn't be a thing. Absolutely.
But the time and the place
to do that, first of all,
it's a lot less common than people think.
The frontal assault should be
the exception by a huge margin.
But there are times that
the frontal assault works.
And sometimes when the frontal
assault with another person,
the Times that it is most effective is
when you've spelled spent a lifetime and
built a lifetime of a relationship
that you can go, Dave, this is stupid.
We're not doing it. And I go, okay, Yup.
And I trust you and I don't get defensive
and I don't shrink back down because
I'm cashing in.
Are you cashing in on a lifetime of
not having done it over and over again?
I'm going to just roll over when
you say that. And I'm going,
it's gonna make it worse for me.
But there are times that actually the
frontal assault does work for sure.
And it only works when you've
not done it a thousand times.
After the one time it happens,
the guy is willing to listen to what's
being said. Yeah. And, and there's,
there's other times where the funnel salt
is good and the frontal assault can be
good because you're setting up other
avenues of approach that you're not gonna
actually follow it. Yeah,
yeah, sure. There's, I've,
I've used that approach sometime where
I've gone ballistic about something that
wasn't a big deal,
but what I was really doing was
prepping the battlefield for something,
something else. So yeah, there's
maneuvers that have to happen for sure.
Moving back to the book, tactics is
the employment of units and combat.
Okay.
The objective of tactics is to achieve
military success through a decision in
battle using tactical actions to do
to achieve what decision is central to
marine corps tactics. In the past,
military forces have also have often
only incremental gains when they thought,
when they saw it victory.
Taking a hill here or a town there pushing
the front forward a few kilometers or
adding to the body count,
sometimes these incremental gains were
the result of a competent enemy or the
chaotic nature of war.
Meaning what they're saying there is
like sometimes you're only making these
incremental gains because the enemy is
super competent or nature's crazy. Okay,
so we get that. That can happen and
then it continues many times. However,
commander's saw incremental gains
as a means to achieve victory. Yeah.
Thinking about that, you're looking
at the battlefield and you go,
you know what? We're
going to get this house.
We're going to get that house right
there and we're going to do what?
No matter what,
we're going to get that house and you're
not looking at this whole battlefield,
this whole city, this whole
region, this whole province.
So we look at these little tactical
incremental gains as a means to achieve
victory.
This incremental is to view sees war as
a slow cumulative process and it is best
and is best exemplified by the grinding
attrition tactics seen on the western
front in World War One
there the opponents were more or
less evenly matched in their tactics,
resulted in indecisive action in Vietnam
where the case where the opposing
forces were quite dissimilar in
their military capabilities. Both.
The incremental approach led to
the u s is overreliance on fire,
power and body counts.
This in turn led to the conduct of
military operations that were often
irrelevant to the outcome of war.
Even though a comparison of casualty
ratio ratios appeared favorable.
Think about that.
You're conducting operations that were
irrelevant on the outcome of the war.
How often do I see that in
leadership, in businesses, in life,
people are doing thing that are either
relevant to the outcome of the war and
committing so much time and so many
resources to that and so much individual
human stress. Yeah,
the body count thing in Vietnam, you
know, the more I learn about that,
the more the,
it's such a clear mistake when you
look at it from, from now. Right.
With our hindsight,
and I was just reading an article the
other day from a Vietnam guy, he's like,
yeah, and he's like, yeah, I
think we killed too. I would.
We reported 20 like that was cause
that way, hey, you know, hey everyone,
get the pat on the back. No one else
knows. No one cares. And how many,
how many platoon commanders did that?
Well, every platoon in the company,
so it was 60 it was 60 we killed 60
okay,
and guess what? Even if we did kill 60
guess what? The Vietcong didn't care.
Yeah, they were there
for the long war. Yeah,
but on some spreadsheet 60
means we're winning. Yup. Yup.
60 versus we took two
casualties. Cool. We're going to,
we're going to beat them. We're going to
win. Yup. Back to the book. Therefore,
the Marine Corps has
embraced a more flexible,
imaginative and effective way
to wage war maneuver warfare.
That is the way you should picture every
thing that you do in your life should
be maneuver warfare.
Marine success with this approach has
been demonstrated in places like Greneda
and the Persian Gulf.
In contrast to tactics based on an
incremental attrition tactics and maneuver
warfare always aim at decisive action.
That's what you want your, that's
what you want to be looking for.
This is what Echo Charles refers
to as the long war. He says, well,
I mean he doesn't, he
does refer to that boats,
but he says that that's the biggest thing
that he's learned and if he wishes he
knew one thing from sitting in here
for all these hours listening to me,
he wishes that he knew that he wishes
that he understood the long war at a
younger age. For sure. I feel, I think
everybody probably feels like that.
I certainly feel like that and the reason
life mirrors that is because life is
life. Life has a campaign. Life is
life is as long as it is and you have,
maybe in life you might have four or
five culminating events in your life.
You might get, if you get lucky,
you just get a handful of those and
if you miss those, if you don't,
if you're not aware that you're
working towards those, you'll do it.
A lot of people do is look back and
say, boy, I wish I had dot, dot, dot,
whatever that is.
And that recognition that it's the same
thing as the campaign and you have to
actually,
everything you do affects something
else and you need to be working towards
whatever that culminating event is.
And if you're lucky, you get a few.
And if you miss them, you spend a
lifetime looking back, wishing you hadn't.
And in combat, if you miss a culminating
event, you can lose, you can lose,
you can lose your guys, you can lose the
war, you can, you can lose everything.
You and I were with a client
and I actually, I actually like,
we were with a date with them for a day
and I was like gonna close out the day.
And I had like some little thing, um,
that I had talked about
at the end of the day.
And as soon as I got done,
I realized I wish I would've
said something else.
And here's what I would've said. Cause we,
you and I were reading the surveys and
one of the things that we read on the
survey, someone said,
Hey, uh, this training,
because you'd worked with this
client before, someone said, hey,
the training with, you
know, Dave was cool,
but it was kind of like seeing a rocky
movie and at the end of a rocky movie,
everybody wants to go home and,
and box and train and work out
and then two days later you're,
you're not doing any of those things
and I what I should have done and I,
it hit me as soon as I walked off stage.
It's just one of those bad timings.
I should have said, hey, I should have
brought up those surveys and said,
I'm gonna read you what someone said.
And what someone said is this is like a
rocky movie and everyone wants to train
boxing and then two days later you're
back to normal and I should just sit the
person who, whoever wrote that in this
room, and I'm not going to call you out,
whoever wrote that is 100% right.
You are 100% right because
this is not an inoculation.
You're, we know you're
going to be fired up,
but you the what it takes
to change leadership inside
of a Co company is not one
brief or two briefs from
Dave. What it takes,
it's a campaign that you have
to think about every single day.
You have to think about the long
war. You're not going to go,
you can't sit through a three hour
briefing and expect that, oh, now,
well now our leadership is good
to go. No, it's not like that.
It's a campaign that you have to get
on. You have to think about it everyday.
You have to train it every day
and actually the same group,
we had done some physical training
with them in the morning, you know,
we put them through like a PT
program. I should've said, okay,
now that we did that PT this morning for
40 minutes who is now in good shape and
no one want to raise their hand.
And I would've said, that's right.
Just because you sat through
three hours with Dave and I,
does this mean that your, your leadership
is now honed and sharp? No, not true.
Just like you have to
continue to workout everyday.
You have to continue to train
and study every single day.
You've continued to be reflective and
look at yourself and see and look at your
peers and talk to each other and see
what you can improve and see what you can
do better. That's what
you need to do. So yes,
in two days you're going to be back
to normal if you allow yourself to be.
But if you get in the game and if you see
this as a campaign and if you see this
as a working out that you
need to do every single day,
and if you look at yourself
for the mistakes that you're
making as a leader and
what mistakes your organization
is making as leaders,
that is when you will become better
at, you can become a champion.
Just like rocky. Unfortunately.
I thought of it like through
like literally 15 seconds
after I walked off. But,
um, you know, and what I
told them was similar but
it wasn't the same. It wasn't
the same. So yeah, I remember,
I remember that conversation. And,
and it also gets to the point to
that no matter where you are in an
organization, you actually can have
massive influence from that position.
If you, if you do that,
you don't have to be the CEO of a company
to steer the company in a particular
direction. And if you actually
recognize, okay, maybe not today,
maybe not turn up, but if I get on
this path and I stay on this path,
I'm going to start to cultivate
a little more influence.
I'm going to get more success.
I'm going to eventually,
you can be the driving force behind
the Organization of the team being
successful. Yes. At
any level, yes you can.
You have so much more.
Just like you have so much more
ownership of things like in your world.
Yet people,
people don't realize how much control and
power they have over their life. Okay.
I get it that there's exceptions. I
get it that there's horrible diseases.
I get it. There's accidents
happen. I get it. I get it. And,
and the sympathy and empathy
that I feel for those situations.
Absolutely. I get it.
There's also so much that you
have control over in your life.
So you have this impact over your life
and it's the same thing in an in an
organization. You Think,
oh, I'm dumb them.
I'm just a middle manager or I'm
just a front line soldier. Okay,
let's see what happens. Let's see
what happens if you get in the game,
I'll tell you what happens. Al Gray. Amen.
He started off as whatever he won
in the United States Marine Corps.
That's what I'm talking
about. How did he do that?
By sitting back and complaining and
pointing his finger at other people. No,
by stepping up and making things
happen. That's how you do it. Hackworth,
young kid, enlisted kid.
Whoa.
Well what did he do? Sit back
and complain or sit back and say,
he didn't have any control. No, he
stepped up. Took ownership of things,
made things happen. Got
a battlefield commission.
You can make these things happen,
whether you get a battlefield
commission or not,
you can make these things happen. I
just see that all the time when I was,
when I was on that training, there'd be a,
if there's a platoon with
like a weak leadership,
like weak platoon commander or
weak platoon chief and it happens,
but there'd be some pipe
hitting e five in there,
just a hard dog and he would have
good leadership skills and he,
I, I had one kid, he was such a beast and,
but he wasn't like letting it out.
They were going through their urban
training and their all pinned down and the
leaders are making no decisions
and I walk over to this kid,
he's pinned down by the wall, it's like
a saw and I'm like, I'm like, hey bro.
And he's like, what's
up sir? And I was like,
you just going to sit here and let
the all this happen. He's like,
w
yeah, kind of like, what do you mean?
And I said, make something happen Bro.
You know what to do. And the the,
the light in his eyes as he just started
to get some and that's all it takes.
Somebody step up and lead so it
doesn't matter where you are in that
organization. If you, if
you look at where you're at,
if you look at where you want to
go longterm, you'll get there.
You will have it, but then
it's not going to be easy. Man.
There were things that I fought for in
the seal teams that I took years and
years and years and some of them
I wasn't successful completely.
I planted seeds that are
still trying to take root,
but that's what you got to do
back to the book. This
does not mean however,
that combat should be viewed as
a bloodless ballet of movement.
I should have read that in of voice.
This does not mean however that combat
should be viewed as a bloodless ballet of
movement. Combat,
especially at the tactical level of war
will be characterized by tough, brutal,
and desperate engagements.
We must remember that war is a violent
clash of two opposing wills in which each
side is trying to rest
advantage from the other.
Our Future enemies may not
allow us to gain, maintain,
or employ technological
or numerical superiority.
The future battle may be bloody and
tough and that makes it vitally important
that we marine leaders strive
to develop tactical proficiency.
Yeah.
What do we mean by achieving a decision?
Take a moment to compare these two
historical examples and Anzio a model of
tactical in decisiveness.
Late 1943 the allies were searching
for a way to alleviate the stalemate.
Natally the campaign installed
around the Casino Wharf,
the Casino Front and resembled the trench
war trench warfare of world war one in
order to keep pressure on the Germans
bypass the stubborn German defenses at
Cassie. No.
Okay.
And capture room. A bold
operation was envisioned.
The U s armies third division and the
British Army's first division would make
an amphibious landing at Anzio
about 35 miles south of Rome.
The allies achieved complete surprise
by landing an Anzio on January 22nd,
1944 under the command of the
u s armies Major General Lucas,
the Americans and British
quickly established a
beachhead and rapidly advance
three miles inland by mid morning
against light German resistance with the
majority of their forces concentrated
further south around casino.
The Germans could not possibly reinforce
the NGO beach had until the January
23rd to 24th if the allies
press their advantage,
the road to Rome lay virtually undefended.
The seizure of Rome would have had the
effect of isolating the German defenders
in the south and firmly establishing
allied control over Italy.
Pretty straight forward situation yet
general Lucas delayed concerned about
being overextended and wanting to build
up his logistics as to our Lucas failed
depresses initial advantage of surprise
and allow the Germans to reinforce the
Anzio area.
Not until January 29th did Lucas feel
strong enough to make an offensive bid,
but by that time it was too late.
The Germans had arrived in force and
had seized the dominating high ground in
the beachhead area. Not only was the
ally defensive and Angio stalled,
but the Germans had seize the initiative
and quickly threatened to drive the
Americans and British back
into the sea. As a result,
the allies did not complete the reduction
of German defenses in southern Italy
and capture Rome until
several months later.
General Lucas lost a
tremendous opportunity to
exploit an initial success and
gain a decisive result
pretty straight forward. Yeah,
it's,
it's easy to sit here
too and be like, cool.
I obviously would've just put
some homework. Right. There's,
and that's what you got to think about.
You got to think about, okay, what,
what did he see, you know, and
how much intelligence did he have?
He might not have known
all this. That being said,
this is one of those
situations where you go, look,
we just made it a shore pretty easily.
We've got, we're doing pretty good.
The Germans aren't in position yet,
and you'd figure that out pretty quickly
and let me tell you something else.
Here's, here's what my mentality
would have been. The Germans. Okay.
Let's say we don't know 100% that the
Germans aren't set up on us, right?
How are we going to find out? You
know how I'm going to find out?
I'm going to go and not sitting here
and I'm not going to sit here and wait.
I'm going to find out.
I'm going to push forward.
I guess what if we push forward and we
meet massive resistance that requires
this extensive logistic train that
I'm waiting for? Cool. Guess what?
It looks like we're going to wait for it,
but if I push start to push through and
all of a sudden I realize that that we
get through, well, guess what? Cool.
We're going to move a little bit further
and I'm going to continue to push,
you know, I talk about,
I've been talking a lot about
this incremental decision
making idea and that's a
great example, right?
It's not okay. We landed,
we're going to go straight to
Rome, but guess what? We landed,
we're three miles in. Guess
what we're going to do tomorrow?
We're going to go five miles in. Guess
what we're gonna do today? After that,
we're going go seven miles
in. Oh, and by the way,
if we start to see like an open road,
we're gonna go until we
meet some resistance.
So I'm not committing 100% day one because
we don't know what we're up against.
We don't know. Because if we run out of
ammunition, we're screwed. We get that.
So I'm gonna make these incremental
decisions that are going to lead me toward
my final objective. But it's going to,
it's going to prevent me from getting
stagnant and waiting and not gaining any
new information. Because
when we're sitting still,
we're not getting any new
information. In a matter of fact,
the enemy's maneuvering, I say it all
the time. If you're sitting still,
the enemy is maneuvering on you.
Here's a classic example and what do
you think the Nazis are going to do?
But the Nazi's aren't going to maneuver
on you. These are the blitz Craig.
People remember them for sure.
We're not sitting back and waiting for
this to happen. We need to go forward.
And obviously again, you
know, this is all for us.
We can sit here and in hindsight and
listen to this and read this and recognize
that, but that's the first
two pages of this book.
That's the leader's job is to recognize
that when you have those culminating
events, when you have the opportunity,
you have to see it and you bring all
your forces to bear to attack that.
Now that doesn't mean that
you just get online and push.
In this case you just pushed the
$30 from. That's not what it means,
but it means that this is our time
to take the things that we have,
the all the things available
to us to do that. And we,
we get aggressive when we attack in it.
And what I'm saying is I'm actually
giving away a pragmatic tool that you can
technically use with, cause I'm not
saying you, we can look back and say,
Hey, the decision should have been
this or this. What I'm saying,
here's a pragmatic tool that you can
use as a leader, which is the following.
You see an opening press press.
You don't need to go crazy. No.
You press and you evaluate. Yes.
See what happens in that room and
actually that's a better chance to reveal
what's actually happening.
Then not pressing,
which is different than everybody get
on and run. That's not what I'm saying,
but moved to the next one and the best
intelligence you're going to get is that
the point of friction and if there's
not a lot of friction here, good chemo,
hey, there's way more friction
than we expected or can deal with.
Now we know and we can actually
respond to that as well. Check
another example. Kenai,
the clear tackle decision
achieved on August 2nd two 16 BC,
the Carthaginian General Hannibal fought
the Roman army under the command of
Terentino's Gerontius Varo near the
city of Kenai and southern Italy.
Hannibal based.
His tactics on the specific
characteristics of both
forces and on the aggressive
personality of the Roman commander. Oh,
I highlighted that in
my notes because listen,
that handle basis tactics on the specific
characteristics of both forces and on
the aggressive personality
of the Roman commander. Yeah,
he knows borrows Varo. He knows that
that dude likes to get aggressive. Yeah.
Cool. I got you pegged.
Here we go. As dawn broke,
Hannibal drew up his force of
50,000 veterans with his flank,
with his left link anchored on
the Aphid Dis River secured from
envelopment by the more numerous Romans.
So you've got on your left leg,
you're protected, you've got a river,
they're great. His center line
contains only a thin line of infantry.
His main force was concentrated on the
flanks, is his left and right wings.
Each contained deep
Phalanxes of heavy infantry.
8,000 cavalry tied to his left line to
the river are tied his left leg to the
river, 2000 cavalry protected
his open right flank.
8,000 men guarded his camp in the
rear Varo and more than 80,000 Romans.
So they're out numbered by
Hannibal's out numbered by 30,000
Varo and more than 80,000 Romans
accepted the challenge seeing the
well-protected Carthaginian flanks
Varo dismissed any intent to envelop.
He decided to crush his opponent
by sheer weight of numbers.
He placed 65,000 men in a
center, 2,400 cavalier owners,
his 4,800 calvary on his left and sent
11,000 men in to attack the Carthaginian
camp. Following preliminary skirmishes.
Hannibal moved His light center line
forward to a salient against the Roman
center. And when they say salient,
that's like a, it's like a PR.
It's like a projection. It's like a
a group that's gonna move forward.
It's like a point, almost like a point
element, but it's a big point element.
Then his heavy calvary on the left
crushed the opposing Roman cavalry and
swung completely around the Roman to
Roman rear to attack the Roman
cavalry on the other flank.
The Roman cavalry fled the field.
The Carthaginian heavy casualty cavalry
then turned back to assault the rear of
the defense, the rear of
the dense Roman infantry,
who had pressed back handles thin
center line at the same time, Hannibal,
his right and left wings into
the flanks. The Roman center,
the Romans were boxed in,
unable to maneuver or use their weapons
effectively between 50,000 and 60,000
Romans died that day as borrows.
Army was destroyed. So battle,
the Psalm had 60,000
casualties in one day.
This is 60,000 dead.
No, your opponent don't be.
This is don't be over aggressive
to Varo was over aggressive.
Wasik IC your thin line. Watch
this. Yeah, watch this as right.
Understanding decisiveness.
What did these examples tell us
about achieving a decision at first?
Achieving decision is
important and indecisive,
but battle waste the lives of
those who fight it and die in it.
It wastes the efforts of those who
survive as well. All the costs, the desks,
the wounds, the sweat and effort,
the equipment destroyed or used up,
the supplies expended or
suffered for little gain.
Such battles have no meaning except for
the comparative losses and perhaps an
incremental gain for
one side or the other.
I've been talking about being a black
belt in Jujitsu and how a black belt in
Jujitsu, when you grabbed something
that doesn't matter, they don't care.
What they want is the decisive
thing. That's what they want.
They want the decisive position.
They want the decisive movement,
and that's the difference. And that's
what they're talking about here. You,
when you do things that are indecisive,
that they're not, they're not gonna,
they're not gonna make or break the
battle. That's what's happening.
It's not gonna make or break the battle.
It's just you're just wasting
wasting energy wasting.
And in war you're wasting
humans and you're wasting
equipment and you're wasting
ammunition and supplies. And for a
leader, think about what that means.
When you do things that
waste your people's Times,
and certainly in this case,
waste their lives. Obviously
that's an extreme situation,
but even just wasting their efforts when
you do things that wasted their effort
over time,
your credibility as a leader and even
your opportunity to be successful in the
long run, every single time
you do that, it goes down.
And that failure to recognize
that this tactical thing,
we're going to stay late to do this
one thing because this thing needs to
happen. And there are
times it's actually true,
but there are times that
if you continually wasted
your people's efforts of
venture,
they recognize you actually don't care
about what it is that we're doing.
And over time your credibility leader
goes away because you don't recognize that
these tactical things you're trying
to get solved are all leading you down
towards, in this case, the
destruction of an army. Yeah.
And here's what you just said and
I'm going to add something to you,
said you don't care about what we're
doing and what's even going to drive these
people into a worse situation from a
leadership perspective is they're going to
realize that you don't care about them,
you don't care about them.
And y'all haven't done a good job
when when general Mooka Yama was milk,
he put this massive emphasis on caring
about your people and like making sure
they understand. And if you,
cause when you ask him why he loved
Hackworth so much, it's like, oh,
because Hackworth care. Care about
me. Yeah. So the most important thing,
the most important thing is like,
oh yeah, we, we, I get, I'm,
I'm definitely concerned
about what we're doing.
The most important thing I
care about is you troops.
Now we have a mission
to do. And by the way,
the mission that we're going
to do is going to benefit us,
all of us in the long run
because when we win this war,
our kids don't have to go to war
and we're going to have stability.
We're going to have security.
And that's what our goal is.
So it benefits us and there's going
to be sacrifice in the short term.
But that's what we're here to do.
We're not here to make any sacrifices
that aren't required. Yeah. At all.
Ever. That's the most important thing.
I care about you, my
troops. I care about you.
I want you to win. I want you to survive.
I want you to be taken care of and we
have a mission to do and we're gonna do
it. But the men, if they put the
mission, benefits you as well, right?
It's not just, hey, you're
going to die for me. No,
that's not what we're
talking about at all.
We're going to put our lives at risk
because we have something we're trying to
accomplish that is going to benefit each
and every one of our families in our
lives, in our country.
That that idea in business
and that idea is so important,
that belief that
that you care about your people so much,
that they recognize the point that they
would be willing to do anything for you.
And it doesn't mean you don't ask
your people to go do hard things.
It doesn't mean you don't put them in
very difficult situations by which their
lives might actually be lost.
That's not what it means to care about
you means I don't put you at risk.
Sometimes I actually do put
you at risk, but if a leader,
and it's not just an,
it's actually believing.
If a leader actually believes that
his people are that important and as a
subordinative I work for someone and
go, holy cow, this guy actually he,
he cares about me that much.
I would literally be willing
to do anything for that person,
but it actually comes from
that understanding that
this person I worked for,
he doesn't just care about the mission
being accomplished for the mission sake
or even for his own sake,
that he recognizes it
actually in my best interest.
That's a rare thing.
That's what cultivates young marines or
young people willing to do anything for
you and leaders get that backwards
all the time. They don't.
They recognize that.
They fail to recognize that they're the
thing that will allow them to do the
hardest things they need to do is by
having those people believe in them that
much.
Yet I'm going to put up an actual
quantifiable amount cause you,
you, you, you just said it
twice. You said that much.
You said the leader cares
about you that much.
You said it sort of in the beginning of
your statement and you just said it at
the end.
I'm going to quantify what much
means cause it's really easy to do.
The way you quantify how much a leader
has to cook care. How much is it?
It's the leader cares more
about the person than they
do about themselves and if
that's what the troops see, if that's
what they see, that's when you get,
as you said, young marines, young or
employees or soldiers, sailors, airmen,
marines, up linemen,
uh, construction guys,
manufacturing people, whoever it is.
When they see that they
will know and that,
that then they will go that
extra distance for you.
Hey is it every single
one of those guys? No,
because you've got people that are self
centered and now we're gonna look at you
and go, cool, I'm going to take
advantage of this guy. That happens.
It does happen. Got Up. You gotta be
where you got to not even be wary of it.
You just need to understand it for sure,
but that's what you need to do. Yeah,
and you can't fake that, that no,
you can't fake that it
don't make no money there.
That is a leader is something
you have to believe.
You have to believe that feeling of they
are actually more important than those
things in some places come very naturally
with your kids. That comes naturally,
but you can't fake that and they
will see right through that and that,
that feeling as a leader, that's hard,
but
okay.
It's actually, it's possible.
I have worked for people that I've come
to realize they care about me more than
them.
They are willing to endure more of
themselves for my benefit and it's almost
always the other way
around and those people,
those few times I've worked for people
like that, I would literally do anything.
Anything for that person work.
Second, achieving a decision is not easy.
History is littered
with indecisive battle.
Sometimes it was enemy skill and
determination that prevented a Vic,
even a victorious commander from
achieving the the decision he sought.
In other cases,
commanders fought a battle without
envisioning a larger result for their
actions.
Yeah.
Again, this is long war. Sometimes even
with the vision of making the decisive,
making the battle decisive,
they cannot achieve their goals due to
the chaos and friction that is the nature
of war and make decisive
victory so difficult.
That leads to the third lesson. Our
examples point out to be decisive,
a battle or an engagement
must lead to a result
yawned itself.
Okay.
Must lead to a result beyond itself.
Within a battle.
An action that is decisive must lead
directly to winning in the campaign or war
as a whole. For the battle to be decisive,
it must lead directly to a larger
success in the war as a whole.
Okay.
Don't really even need to comment
on that except for to say,
how often do people and businesses
do things and fight battles?
They fight battles that have no bearing
and no result beyond the battle itself.
You see people shooting themselves all
the time with this very idea they're
going to win that war. They're going
to win that argument with their wife,
right? Oh yeah. They're going to win
that battle. What does it lead to?
They're going to lead.
They're going to win that
argument with their subordinate,
or if they're going to win
that argument with their boss,
where does it lead them? Oh yeah.
Well, that worked out great for you.
It actually sets you back
in your campaign. You don't
think about that though.
Okay.
On the other hand, we must not seek
decisiveness for its own sake. Oh,
by boom dichotomy coming at
you. We do not, after all,
seek a decision if it is
likely to be against us.
We seek to insure in so far as this is
possible given the inherent uncertainties
of war, that the battle will go our way.
Okay?
We have stacked the deck in our favor
before the cards are laid on the table.
Otherwise, to seek decisive bond
battle is an irresponsible gamble.
Okay?
If you're, if you see
me, Jocko, if you see me
engaged with someone,
okay.
I already know the outcome.
Like when I'm talking,
when I'm discussing someone, some
of them I already know the outcome.
Yeah.
Because I've already laid that
out in my head. Otherwise,
I'm just listening to you.
I'm just going to listen to you
because I'm learning and I'm not gonna.
I'm not going to step onto
the battlefield. Right.
I'll talk to you and we'll discuss
possibilities and outcomes and plans and
that's, that's great.
I will not take a stand until I actually
know what the outcome is going to be.
Just FYI and you've done all the things
that you need to do prior to that up to
including that conversation. Yes. To
know what that is. Yes. Because if not,
then you're just arguing for argument
arguments sake and then you might win the
argument, which is great. Yeah. Only it
won't actually help you in the long run.
Exactly. When we seek battle,
we must seek victory accomplishment
of the assigned mission.
That leads to further significant gains
for the forest as a whole. At Anzio.
The allied aim was to break
the stalemate in the south,
opening up a southern front that would
force Germany to move additional forces
from the defense.
Enormity this weakening
of normally defenses would
support our planned invasion
of France later that same year at
Kenai cartridge one cartridge one,
one round.
And it's long contention with Rome for
the domination of the Mediterranean.
These tactical battles were planned
for their overall operational strategic
effect.
The consequences of a tactical engagement
should lead to achieving operational
and strategic goals. Please everyone,
please don't fight battles unless
they're gonna help you win strategically.
Okay?
Yeah. The battle for the battle sake
doesn't help you in those examples too.
We're not doing an amphibious landing
on Tarawa to do an amphibious landing on
Tara one.
We're doing an a feminist landing on Toro
to salvage the beachhead specifically.
So the next,
the final thing we'll do is push
the enemy off the island or kill it.
And it's that saying that
we got here, we established,
we accomplished this mission and this,
this tactical thing, this battle.
That's actually not what we're
doing. That's a step. In fact,
we're not even just pushing him
off. Tarwater. That's not the goal.
The goal isn't to push some other
goal four years down the road. Yeah.
Absolute goal is two years down the
road. The goal is we're going to put a,
we're going to put airplanes
here that we can then bomb Japan.
That's what we're doing. Yes.
Okay.
Next section. Military judgment.
Once we understand what is meant by the
term decisive and why does it important
to seek a decision? A question
naturally arises, how do we do it?
There is no easy answer to that question.
Each battle will have its own unique
answers. As with so much in warfare,
it depends on the situation.
Know formula, process,
acronym or Buzzword
can provide the answer.
Okay.
No formula, process, acronym or
Buzzword can provide the answer.
Rather the [inaudible] and you wouldn't
guess that if you saw, if you saw,
if you go online, even with the,
even what they do with like me,
they'll do an article on me. Three
things a leader needs to do. It's, yeah,
there's three. That's definitely a three.
Those are three? Yup. There's three.
But guess what? You need to actually
learn the art behind the science. Rather.
The answer is in military judgment
and the ability of the commander to
understand the battlefield and act
decisively. Military judgment is to,
is a developed skill that is honed by
the wisdom gained through experience
combined with situational awareness.
Military judgment allows us
to identify emerging patterns,
discern critical vulnerabilities,
and concentrate combat power.
The beauty of that is the Marine Corps,
the Marine court understands that those
traits, that attribute of judgement,
that attribute of decisiveness,
those can be developed.
Those can be learned.
Those aren't just innate natural capacity
that we just happen to bring these
people into the Marine Corps.
That's one of the traits that the Marine
Corps recognizes that we have to teach
people to learn decisiveness and teach
people the quality of judgment and they
breed that in their marines and they
train and teach them. Now, yeah,
some are better than others, no
doubt about it, but these qualities,
these things, and we're talking
about how important these are,
not just in the military but in the
private sector. These can be learned.
These can be evolved and
developed inside everybody.
T to what degree is it
certainly different,
but everybody can get better
at this, almost everybody.
Okay.
True. Right. Yeah, no, you're
right. Absolutely. And I,
I'm speaking in absolutes
and, and, and everybody,
and really what I should be saying
is not just, I shouldn't say it,
that everybody has to
say almost everybody,
but I should say we have so much more
capacity to evolve these things than we
think we do. Yeah. And by the way,
just in case no one was paying attention
to what I've been saying for the last
25 years. When I say
almost everybody, the,
almost the person that
I can't teach this to,
the person that can't improve
their military judgment
is the person that already
thinks they have good days and no one
knows it all yet is the person that thinks
that they already have the
wisdom that that person,
they're not going to
get any better. In fact,
they're going to get worse because
they'll reinforce their ideas.
So if you have an open mind, you can
get way better at this stuff. Yeah.
If you don't have an open
mind, you won't get any better
understanding the situation,
the first requirement of commanders
to understand the situation.
You would think that that was just so off,
so self evident that you
wouldn't even say it in the book,
but how often am I dealing with
the leader, military, civilian,
another human being
just going through life.
They don't even understand
the situation that they're in.
That's why we have to save
this out loud in a book.
The first requirement of commander
is to understand the situation.
The successful tacticians studies the
situation to develop it as mind to clear
picture of what is happening,
how it got that way,
and how it might develop further
considering the factors of mission, enemy,
terrain and weather troops and
support available. This has met,
met t the commander must think through
all actions determine the desired result
and ascertain the means
to achieve that result.
Part of the commander's thinking should
also include assuming the role of the
enemy,
considering what the enemies best course
of action may be in deciding how to
defeat it. Thinking through these elements
helps the commander develop increased
situational awareness. So yes,
study the situation,
study how it got that way,
study how it might further develop.
It's interesting when we work
with companies cause you,
you get with the first thing you
get is kind of where they're at.
Like here's where we're at right now and
then you start getting filled in on on
how it got the out there. And those
are some interesting stories often.
And then we're looking at how it could
develop because one thing we know is if
we develop leaders and we
start to get on the path,
it's going to develop in a great
way and if we don't do that,
it's going to be problematic. Yeah.
Based on this understanding
of the situation,
the commander can begin to form a
mental image of how the battle might be
fought.
Central to the commander's thinking
must be the question and this situation,
what efforts will be decisive?
The commander asked this one, this
question, not just once, but repeatedly.
As the battle progresses,
the commander must also address the
possible outcomes and the new situations
that will result from those
possibilities. As the situation changes,
so will the solutions and the
actions that derive from it.
You always have to
reassess what's going on.
For every situation,
the leader must be able to decide which
of the countless and often confusing
pieces of information are
important and reliable.
The leader must determine what the enemy
is trying to do and how to counter his
efforts.
The leader's skill is essentially
one of pattern recognition.
The ability after seeing only a few pieces
of the puzzle to fill in the rest of
the picture correctly.
Pattern recognition is the ability to
understand the true significance and
dynamics of a situation
with limited information.
Pattern recognition is a key skill
for success on the battlefield.
Get those overlays out.
Tack tactics requires leaders to make
decisions and leader must make decisions
in a constantly changing environment
of friction, uncertainty and danger.
Making effective decisions and acting
on those decisions faster than the enemy
is a crucial element of
Marine Corps tactics.
Okay.
Making decisions faster.
Sometimes there are some of them.
There may be time to analyze situations
deliberately and consider multiple
options.
Comparing several options and selecting
the best one is known as analytical
decision making.
When time allows a commander to
apply analytical decision making,
usually before an engagement
or before battle begins,
the commanders should make the most of
it absolutely once engaged. However,
the commander finds time is short and
the need and the need for speed is
paramount. In some cases,
speeding up the analytical decision
process may be sufficient. However,
in most cases,
intuitive decision making is needed
to generate and maintain tempo.
Intuitive decision making relies on a
commander's intuitive ability to recognize
the key elements of a particular problem
and arrive at the proper decision
without having to
compare multiple options.
Intuition is not some mysterious
reality, not some mysterious quality.
Rather, it is a developed skill grounded,
firmly inexperienced and one that can be
further developed through education and
practice is not without
some risk. However,
and leaders should use the decision
making style that works for them.
Learn to detach, learn
to take a step back,
make the intuitive decision making
credible, incremental decisions.
Okay.
You know, Brian Stann when
Brian San was on here,
I'll have to go listen to it again.
But one thing I noticed is he always,
he was really into the tempo and, and
I, I paid attention to that. He said,
Yo, I wanted to keep the temple when
you, you, you, you know, certain people,
they sort of, they sort of
grasp onto a tenant and,
and it makes really good sense to them.
And when Stan was on like
I could see, oh yeah. He,
the way he talked about
maintaining that temple, you know,
he had a good instructor at that
block of the basic school. Yeah.
He really explained it well and
he said, okay, I get this. I can,
I can see if I can go, if
I can keep that speed up,
if I can keep that operational
tempo up, I can overcome my enemy.
Yeah.
I love how they described the idea of
being intuitive is not magic or mystery.
Yeah. And people write that off like, oh,
he's got people that are naturally
intuitive actually aren't naturally
intuitive.
They've cultivated and developed that
through a ton of experience at and the
discipline to put themselves in those
situations over and over and over again.
And for those of us on the outside
looks like it's just natural. Yeah.
But it's really a byproduct of all the
Times that they've done that. So it is,
it is natural to them only because of
what they've done to put those on that
position. Yeah.
And there's like pragmatic things that
you can do to make yourself seem super
intuitive. And I do them all
the time there. For instance,
and I was just writing about this,
I'll sit there and there'll be a group
of my subordinates talking about whatever
thing we got to decide on and I'm not
saying a damn word and I'll listen and
I'll get all this great information
from all of them about all the different
possibilities of things, way
things go in a way. Things,
the outcomes we could have and the
resistance we could meet in these various
areas. And I get done listening
to all that for 28 minutes.
Then I haven't said anything,
but guess what I've done is I've taken
all those things and by being detached
and by listening and by not
having a preformed opinion
and by letting my ego not
drive my decision making.
When I finally say, Hey,
okay,
here's the best way to go forward.
Okay.
It seems like, oh, the bubbles was both.
He made that decision really easily.
No, actually it's, it's
because I just listened.
There's pragmatic things you can do
that can make you seem more intuitive.
An incremental decision is one of those
things as well because you can make an
incremental decisions very easily
because there's less risk in it.
Okay,
so when you say, Hey, listen,
we just landed and the the Germans,
we haven't had many resistance.
We're going forward.
We're going to go forward three more
miles. That seems like a really bold,
intuitive decision,
but really you haven't met any resistance
and it's pretty easy to make because
you're not over committing, so,
so you seem like the super cool.
You're not saying, hey, we're going all
the way to Rome. You're just saying,
hey, we're just going to go three
more miles. We made it three,
we're going to double it. Let's go at
different things. Damn, that's bold. Yeah,
but the reality is you haven't
met any stern resistance. Cool.
Let's rock and roll.
Okay.
Am I super intuitive?
No, I'm just detached.
I'm assessing and making a
decision or, well, you know,
I find myself kind of
laughing. I'm hearing you.
You read it and I kind of
chuckled to myself a little bit.
There is the reason these seemingly
totally simple and obvious statements need
to be said like you need to assess the
situation and figure out how we got here
like that. It's so easy to listen to that,
but in reality it's really
hard people to do that and the
people that do that,
the worst are the ones that
are most emotional about
what's going on to the most
inside. We we talk about at echelon
front, when we talk with companies,
we talk about detach. When we're
talking about prioritize and execute,
and if I say prioritize and execute,
the first thing that people jump to is
I've got to get the right resources and
make sure I know what the right
priorities are. That is true,
but actually individually what you need
to do is you need to detach from what's
going on and make sure that what seems
to be a priority for you isn't a priority
because you're so inside that
and so emotional about that,
that you can't see that
actually this thing changed.
Step beat took us to this and and things
are different now we have to shift our
priorities and it isn't just people out,
the resources allocated to the
right things. Those are true.
It's are you detached from the situation
so you're actually doing that correctly
so you don't stay in one place too long
or pushed too far forward or anything in
between and sounds right at the say
you needed to attach and pay attention.
Look what's going on around you.
And we kind of laugh that it's
so hard for some people to do,
especially when it's your thing
that you're living on the inside.
And when you do that as a commander and
do that as a leader in an organization,
you can crush organizations by being so
committed to the thing that you're doing
in one direction or another because
you're simply just not detached.
And when you can show people
what detachment looks like
and just pull them out a
little bit and you look around,
I was at an FTX two weeks ago,
so we do this FTX it's in there. They
can be very chaotic, very dynamic.
There's things going on
in more often than not,
when you're leading your team
in this FTX is field training.
You're getting slaughtered by
the enemy. There's 15 of you,
there's three of them and
they're destroying you because
they'd see what's going
on. And the leaders run around
and they try to make decisions.
And I grabbed someone who was, who was
dead. So he puts out hate, sat them down,
pull them up.
And I sat him next to me and I took about
20 steps away from the action. I said,
what do you see? Just tell me
what you see. And they say, Oh,
I see a group over here running.
I see someone getting cover.
I see two enemy running
behind that building.
And they went on and said
about 15 different things
that they saw. And I said,
you know what you see
actually you see everything.
You're just standing here looking around
cause you're totally detaching and
what, what do you think
we should do? He said,
oh those people need to get from
behind that building and run over here.
Like that's what a good leader does.
And when they can see that from the
outside instead of the inside out,
all this stuff becomes obvious
and we're listening, you know,
leading reading it and
sort of laughing about it.
But it's actually really hard to do when
you're inside that. Yeah, that's the,
that's the classic Seth Stone Story.
I tell him when he had his neck brace
on during land warfare and he wasn't
allowed to participate and he said,
they're watching is his to ask you to
get annihilated. And he says, you know,
can I help them? And I said, well,
hold on a minute and then they're going
to be annihilated anymore. And I says,
can I help them? And I said, all
right, go ahead and help him.
And he gives them, you know,
one quick immediate action drill
and they executed and they're gone.
And he says to me, man, it's so
easy when you're way up here.
And we were literally six
inches above the task dude.
But when you're, and then I told
him, you know, when we were going
through this training,
it was like this for me.
Every time I could see everything because
I was detached, I wasn't in the weeds.
And that's gives you,
gives you this in car ratable power
and visibility and it happens,
does it? We're not only, here's the
thing, we're not only talking about,
well the battlefield or
the trainings and Arrow,
we're talking about any situation.
We're talking about business and yes,
we're talking about life
as well. Take a step back.
I had a friend that was falling
off the cliff with addiction,
alcohol, alcohol addiction.
And he was briefing me on another person
that we knew that was fallen off the
cliff of drug addiction.
And he's sitting there explaining this
to me. Like, I can't believe your kids.
He doesn't even see what's happening.
It's so bad. And he doesn't get it.
He can't see how bad it is for himself.
And I'm sitting there and I was,
I was going to the extreme. I was
good. I know. I can't believe how hard,
I can't believe he can't see that.
And I was describing him. Yeah.
Cause we can't detach.
We get caught in relationships and jobs
and scenarios that are bad because we
can't attach and we'd get
emotional, so don't let it happen.
Leaders with strong situational awareness
and broad experience can act quickly
because they have intuitive
understanding of the situation,
know what needs to be done
and know what can be done.
Okay.
This insight has often
been called Ku, do we?
Yeah,
which is a French term and we've
talked about it on this podcast,
which literally means a stroke the I,
which means you take a quick glance at
something and you can understand it.
It's also been called Tactical Sense
Union army re-did General John Buford's
approach to the battle of Gettysburg
offers a good example of understanding the
battle so that it leads to a decision
arriving at Gettysburg with a division of
cavalry. In the morning of June 30th,
1863 Buford saw confederate
forces approaching from
the northwest with the bulk
of the union forces still some miles away.
Buford was able to conceptualize
the coming battle in his
mind from his position
on a hill outside of town.
Okay.
He's defacto detached.
He could see that early seizure of
the high ground west at Gettysburg was
critical to giving the army of the
Potomac time to mass its forces.
Op occupation of this high ground would
also preserve tactical advantage of the
high ground to Buford's rear for the
Union army once they arrived on the
battlefield.
Buf Buford also knew that
if the confederates were
allowed to mass forces first
around the high ground to the south and
west Lee would have the advantage over
the arrive Union forces quickly spreading
out one brigade west of town along
Macpherson's Ridge General Buford
settled in to defend Gettysburg until the
arrival of union reinforcements
on July 1st the following day,
he held his ground against the
division of confederate infantry,
supported by artillery until John Reynolds
second core came up and reinforced
the line. General Buford's ability
to foresee the coming battle,
take quick action in the disposition
of his forces and hold the high ground
until reinforcers one of the different
decisive actions that defeated the army
of Northern Virginia.
At the battle of Gettysburg Buford's
actions at Gettysburg demonstrated an
exceptional ability to grasp the essence
of a tactical situation through the
skills of pattern
recognition, recognition, and
intuitive decision making.
I'm going to say that when you get up
on the high ground and you look around,
you can see things that
other people aren't going to
see and you can make really
good decisions. Now, this
is a physical example,
but you can mentally do this
as well and you have to,
you have to mentally step back, detach,
acting decisively.
Our ability to understand the situation
is useless if we're not prepared to act
decisively when the opportunity arrives,
we must exploit it fully and aggressively.
Committing every ounce of combat power
we can muster and pushing ourselves to
the limits of exhaustion.
The keys to this effort are identifying
enemy critical vulnerabilities,
shaping the operation
area to our advantage.
Designating a main effort to focus our
combat power and acting in a bold and
ruthless manner.
Critical vulnerabilities
for battlefield success.
It is not enough to generate
superior combat power.
We must focus that combat
power. Hmm, interesting.
We must concentrate our
efforts on a critical,
critical vulnerability that
is a vulnerability which
permits us to destroy some
capability without which the
enemy cannot function effectively.
Seeking the enemies of vulnerabilities
means striking with our strength against
his weakness rather than his
strength and at a time in the end,
he's not prepared. This
is where we can often
cause the greatest damage at the lowest
cost to ourselves. In practical terms,
this means avoiding his front.
Yeah.
The frontal assault where his attention
is focused and striking his flanks and
rear we did not, does not expect us.
Yeah,
so yes, the frontal assault, it
does exist and it can be used.
Yeah.
Not the best option. Very
often. Not the best option.
Just because a target is vulnerable
does not however mean that it's worth
attacking.
We must direct our resources and strike
those capabilities that are critical to
the enemy's ability to
function, to defend, attack,
or sustain himself or
to command his forces.
We must focus our efforts on
those critical vulnerabilities
that will bend the
enemy most to are well, most quickly.
You know what that makes me think
of when that makes me think.
When I see leaders get focused
on things that don't matter,
that they're going to get
critical about. So you know, Dave,
you're doing 10 things, six,
three of them are really
important for our organization.
There's two of them that are at the
bottom end that aren't really like a big
impact at all. You're doing
your top three pretty well.
You're letting one of your bottom
two just like doing it horribly.
I might mention a little something
about it just to make sure it doesn't go
completely off the rails, but I've seen,
I see leaders that they take all that
focus in and focus on something that
doesn't matter. They want
to get mad about you,
you should've done this or you
should've done that. And I'm thinking,
where are you really going to expend your
leadership capital on that thing that
barely even matters? You know, going
back to the patches with me and life,
you know, hey, I'm not going to
expend a bunch of liters of capital.
And the fact that you are aware
of these patches. You know what,
I don't like it, but cool. Let's,
let's move on. I what I want you to do,
life and Seth, I want you guys to
plan an execute awesome missions.
I want you to take the fight to the enemy
that that's the top things I want you
to do. Do I want you to dress
professionally? Yes, I do.
But that's pretty low on the totem pole
given where we are in this situation
right now. Yeah. And leaders, we'll,
we'll create this, this scenario by which,
okay, if I, if I acquiesce
on that one little thing,
that's a weakness and they're going to
see that I don't hold the line on that
and so it's gonna effect everything
else. And so they, they'll,
they'll overdo that one thing because
I hold the, that's how I lead.
I hold the line on
everything when in reality,
the exact opposite will happen is,
is they'll recognize it. John Goes,
actually a human being, hey,
and I'm not going to just completely
GAF off Jocko and ignore what he says.
He's kind of these give me
a little indication, hey,
don't let this thing fall solar off
the rails that it then starts to affect
everything else,
but what actually is important is what
we're focusing on and the inflexibility
we see leaders like, well, I'm going
to hold the line on everything.
Well guess what?
Not Everything is the same importance
and not everything will have the same
impact on the outcome and what you need
to focus on the most is a things that
are most impactful. Things
that are most important,
patches, patches, patches on good job life
at the, at the lower tactical level,
this may mean using fire maneuver
to take out machine gun position.
That is backbone event. That is
the backbone of enemy defenses.
It may mean using a gap in the enemy's
field of fire that allows us to get into
his rear, get to the rear of his position.
It may mean exploiting the enemy's lack
of air defenses by calling in close air
support. It may mean taking advantage of
an enemy's lack of mobility by rapidly
overrunning a key position
fashion that you can respond.
It made me an interdicting
enemy. Re Re supply routes.
When his supplies are running short,
they may mean exploiting a lack of long
range weapon tree by employing standoff
tactics.
When whatever we determined the
enemy's critical vulnerability to be,
we must be prepared to
rapidly take advantage of it
in the business world. That's,
that's something you should always be
paying attention to cause we got our
business and that's cool. We're going
to do our thing, but what where,
what weaknesses do those our competitor
have and are we ready to exploit those
weaknesses?
There is no formula for determining
critical vulnerabilities.
Each situation is different.
Critical vulnerabilities
will rarely be obvious.
Okay.
This is one of the things that make
mastery of tactics so difficult and one
reason that so few actions
achieve a decisive outcome.
Identifying critical vulnerabilities is
an important prerequisite to achieving a
decision
shaping the operating area.
Once we have developed an understanding
of the situation and have determined
enemy critical vulnerabilities to attack,
we try to shape the operating
area to our advantage.
Shaping includes both lethal and non
lethal activity such as planning fires to
fix the enemy using acts of
advanced to facilitate movement,
designating objectives to focus our combat
power or using deceptive measures to
reinforce enemy expectations.
I like that using deceptive measures
to reinforce enemy expectations because
they already have that idea,
we're just going to reinforce it.
Shaping activities can make
the enemy vulnerable to attack.
And Peter Divert his attempts to maneuver,
facilitate the maneuver of friendly
forces and otherwise dictate the time and
place for decisive battle shaping forces
the enemy to adopt courses of action
favorable to us.
We attempt to shape events in a way that
allows us several options so that by
the time for the moment,
so that by the time the moment
for decisive action arrives,
we have not restricted ourselves
to only one course of action.
Okay.
Through shaping, we gain the
initiative, preserve momentum,
and controlled the temple combat. So yeah,
we got multiple things
that we're going to do.
Okay.
And we'll pick that course of
action when it develops. Yeah.
We haven't determined ahead of
time which one we're gonna use.
Is it going to be air power artillery?
We haven't actually
made that decision yet,
but we're going to do things that will
reveal their vulnerability and then I'm
gonna apply whatever
that is to crush them.
Now some people might be wondering in a
day to day or in a business environment
or in life, what is it? What are we
talking about? Shaping operations,
and this is a very clear
translation of what this means,
how you shape operations in the
business world and in and in your life.
What shaping operations means is that
you're out building relationships with the
other human beings that you're
going to be working with.
[inaudible]
that's what it means.
We build up alliances,
we build up trust,
we build up relationships so that
when the things start to unfold,
we know who we can count
on, we know where we stand.
Yeah.
And also recognizing they might be the
one that delivers the most critical
event, the most critical action. They
might be the one that at the right time,
at the most critical moment, do the
thing we need them to do. Absolutely.
And if your plan is wait for that moment
to start building that relationship,
it's, it won't work there.
If that's not how it works,
you have to go back in time and you have
to build that with the anticipation and
not even knowing which one
it's going to be at that time,
but their relationship has to be
available. Then you realize it's here.
We need to do this now,
and they're onboard.
Main effort.
The main effort is the central maneuver
is a central maneuver warfare concept.
Concentrating efforts on achieving
objectives that lead to victory.
Yeah.
Of all the actions going
on within our command,
we recognize one as the most
critical to success at that moment.
The unit assigned responsibility for
accomplishing this key mission is
designated as the main effort,
the focal point upon which converges
the combat power of the force.
Okay.
The main effort receives priority
for support of any kind. It must be.
So you've got to look at
your life and say like,
what's your main effort
in your life? Right.
And you got to make sacrifices in other
areas that aren't as important in that
particular time.
And they're going to talk about this to
your main African change. Like it can,
you can adapt. Hey, my main effort right
now, I'm focusing on this thing. Oh,
that change. You know,
I was finishing a book.
Yeah.
I was finishing a book and guess what?
That was my main effort for like, uh,
you know, oh, I actually, it was
the main effort when I was editing.
So you get edits back from
your, from your, uh, editor,
right. And they've got little ideas.
There's a time frame that that's doing.
So I've got, you know,
whatever 80,000 word book,
it's when I'm writing the book,
it's not the main effort because
it's just part of what I'm doing.
It's an hour a day, it's a
thousand words a day. Boom.
I look up in three months and
I've got 80,000 words. Good. Okay.
There wasn't a main effort.
Then all of a sudden I get back my edits
from my editor and now I've got to in,
that's due in six days. That becomes
my main effort. 100% because I can't,
I don't have time. It's gonna take
like three, four hours a day to do the,
to do those edits. So it
has to be the main effort.
So your main effort can
change in your life,
but what you do is you
sacrifice other things.
Like during that time period I was
kind of lucky cause I hurt my knee,
come from beautifully hurt my knee,
couldn't train Jujitsu. I was like cool,
there's that editing needs to get done.
Did it? So your, your main effort can,
can change and adapt. And the same
thing happens on the battlefield.
Yeah.
Faced with a decision, we ask ourselves,
how can I best support the main effort?
Okay,
so the main effort receives
priority for support of any kind.
It must be clear to all of the units in
the command that they must support that
unit in the accomplishment of the mission.
The main effort becomes a harmonizing
force for subordinates initiative.
Faced with a decision we ask ourselves,
how can I best support the main effort?
And if you want to be a good,
if you want to create a good
reputation for yourself as a,
as a leader and as a human being,
when you're not the main effort,
instead of complaining and worried
that you don't have the spotlight,
what you do use, you look at the person
that's the supporting effort. You say,
how can I help you win? Yeah.
Okay.
A good leader says when they
recognize somebody else's,
the main effort is what can I do to help
and all the time we see it where when
you're not the main effort, you
know what the bad leaders do.
They complain that they're not the main
effort and they argue and they fight and
they stamp their foot to say, I
should be main effort and even worse,
they undermine the main shirt because
they want to see the main effort fail.
Dave shouldn't had this.
I'm going to undermine Dave.
Watch him fail and then
I'll get the leg up. Yeah.
How does that help you in the long run?
Oh wait, it does. Oh, that's right.
Because you're playing the short game.
Some actions may support the main
effort indirectly. For example,
a commander may use other
forces to deceive the enemy
as to the location of the
main effort.
Marine forces used this
concept extensively and
conducting a series of combined
arms rates prior to the ground
offensive and Operation Desert Storm.
The raids were to confuse the Iraqis as
to the true position and intention of
allied forces.
The raid force appeared in the middle of
the night and fired from positions the
enemy had every right to
believe were unoccupied.
Use of a main effort implies
the use of economy of force.
This term does not mean that we use as
little force as we think we can get away
with.
Okay.
Rather,
it means that we must not fail to make
effective use of all the assets available
to us.
Forces not in a position to directly
support the main effort should be used to
indirectly support it.
Such forces might be used to distract
the enemy or tie down enemy forces that
might otherwise reinforce
the threatened point.
Uncommitted forces can be used in this
effort by maneuvering them in faints and
demonstrations that keep
the enemy off balance.
Okay,
and this is something that I think you
mentioned earlier is like, oh yeah,
like the the person that's not the
main effort has a huge impact on what's
happening.
So just because you're not the main
effort doesn't mean you shouldn't do
everything in your power
to support the main effort.
While a commander always
designates a main effort,
it may shift during the course of battles.
Events unfold because events
and the enemy are unpredictable.
Few battles flow exactly as the
commander is planned. Isn't that funny?
commander is planned. As a result,
the commander must make adjustments.
How often do I see a commander,
a leader have their plan in their head
and that's what they're sticking to.
Yeah, we see it all the time.
I'm sticking to the plan
and yet few battles flow.
Exactly as the commander you, it's
okay. It's by definition is missing.
You should not stick with your plans
because it's going to change. Yes.
One way is by re-designated
the main effort. For example,
if a company is designated as the
main effort but runs into heavy enemy
resistance while adjacent,
company B makes a breakthrough that as
exploits a critical vulnerability that
battalion commander may designate
company B as the main effort.
This new designation of company B
as a main effort must not however,
be merely nominal. It means
that the combat power,
which was supporting company
a now shifts to company B.
Identifying
the main effort is the principle and
most important answer to the question,
how do we achieve a decision?
Bold
boldness and ruthlessness. You wanna
know how you achieve a decision.
Here's how you do it.
Forcing a successful decision requires
the commander to be bold and ruthless.
Boldness refers to daring and
aggressiveness in behavior.
It is one of the basic requirements
for achieving clearcut outcomes.
In order to try for victory
must dare to try for victory.
We must have a desire to win big even if
we realize that in many situations that
conditions for victory
may not yet be present.
Ruthlessness refers to pursuing the
established goal mercilessly and
singlemindedly this doubly
important. This is doubly important.
Once we gain an advantage,
once we have an advantage,
we should exploit it to the
fullest. We should not ease up,
but instead increase the pressure.
Victory in combat is really your
product of it, of the initial plan,
but rather of ruthlessly
exploiting any advantage,
no matter how small until it succeeds.
And that's where a lot of
people want to stop listening.
Okay?
Just that, that cause that sounds
so fired up that they think cool,
bold and ruthless. That's
[inaudible] from now on.
And then we get into the dichotomy.
Bold and ruthless boldness and ruthless
ruthlessness must be accompanied by
strong leadership and
tempered by sound judgment.
Yeah.
Without these qualities,
boldness can become a recklessness
and ruthlessness can be distorted into
cruelty.
Okay.
So yes, there is a dichotomy
in every aspect of leadership.
And if you go too far in
one direction or the other,
you will fall apart and fail.
Okay.
Can you have, can you have
too much sound judgment?
Oh yes you can. You can sit there and
wait to make the perfect judgment.
Yeah.
That, that, that's, that's what's
gotta be balanced. So be careful.
Conclusion.
Okay.
As marine leaders, whether of fire teams
or of a Marine Expeditionary Force,
we are responsible for achieving
success. As you pointed out earlier,
what are you gonna get graded
on? How if you're successful,
that's how we're grading you. We
don't care how you did it in combat.
The success we seek is victory,
not merely a partial or marginal outcome
that first stalls the final reckoning,
but a victory that settles
the issue in our favor.
Yeah.
To be victorious.
We must work ceaselessly in peace time
to develop in ourselves a talent for
military judgment. The ability to
understand a situation and act decisively.
Military judgment results from
the wisdom gained from experience.
It allows us to identify patterns of
activity and to concentrate our efforts
against a critical vulnerability
that will bend the enemy to our will.
We must sharpen our
ability to make decisions
intuitively based on our
understanding of the situation.
Boom. So we just did two chapters.
I've thought we were going to
get through three, but we did.
So we'll, we'll hit the other five.
What is there? Eight, nine?
No, there's eight chapters.
There's eight chapters in
this book we got through to,
we'll do the next two on the next one. Um,
all kinds of things that sort
of lessons learned inside this.
Okay.
And, and you know, we covered that
part. That was about stacking.
Okay.
The deck in your favorite
skilled commander seeks
victory from the situation.
That's what we're trying to do. We're
trying to stack the deck in our favor.
I'm trying to be ready,
trying to be prepared.
Okay.
Not just for combat obviously,
but for life, for business,
for family.
[inaudible]
any recommendations from you Dave?
I do have some recommendations
on being prepared and yeah,
combat for sure. Business for sure. Uh,
and in life for sure. Um,
okay.
Origin USA. Origin.
Main. Open to Farmington. So
you started Jujitsu how long ago?
Just over a year ago. That really,
it's only been a year, probably
a year and four months I guess.
So just not maybe about two months
before the origin camp. Okay.
Last year. Got It. Which
is coming up next month.
How often do you overlay what you see
in Jujitsu over everything else that
you're doing in your life?
Okay.
All the time.
Now I'm always a little cautious about
talking about it because you're an
experienced, I'm an experienced. Um,
but if you're asking me how often I
think about it and how often I make the
connection to it, it's,
and I say all the time,
I mean it all the time and now
there's another layer to that.
So I've got my kids started on Jujitsu
about probably about six months ago and
we had a little, we moved cross
country, there's a little gap in there,
but I got him set up pretty quickly here
and last week they actually did a week
long Jujitsu camp check where I'm
actually making my money now is how much
better I am at helping my kids starting
to figure things out because they're
doing the Jujitsu and I'm
actually starting to make
connections for them about
their lives and it look, they
don't see it all, they don't.
But the impact of that on my life goes
well beyond my personal life right now.
It's,
it's my kids and how impactful that is
and added to the long of regret in my
life. If I had started when I, when
I was six years old, like my son,
how different my life would be.
But um, it is, it is awesome man.
It's awesome. Yeah,
it's good to be able to discuss
things and be able to explain things.
You have this incredible
metaphor for everything. Yes.
If you get that Jujitsu won't, I
can't give my kids combat metaphors,
but I can give them Jujitsu metaphors
that they actually understand and I'm
amazed at how much more they understand
than I thought because how they're
young, that they understand things and
they understand things. And you know,
the other thing is you can explain things
to them that they might understand.
They don't, they don't understand it.
They understand it subconsciously.
And when you make it conscious for
them and they go, oh, oh, I see. Oh,
so I shouldn't just try
and stay in this position.
I should let that person move a little
bit. And look for an opening. Oh, okay.
Kind of like when mom's telling me to
do something, I shouldn't just get,
just trying to hold position. I should
actually maneuver a little bit. Okay.
I get it. I get it. Oh, I should. I
should try and get in a good position.
Yeah. If you start Jujitsu, which you
absolutely should go to origin main,
you're going to need a
g, go to origin Maine,
get a a g for Jujitsu, get
a rash guard for Jujitsu,
get workout clothes, tee shirts,
get some jeans. We have
origin jeans now and
they're super, they're just super
comfortable and super kicked ass,
so get yourself some of
that. We have supplements,
joint warfare. I just got an
email yesterday from some,
somebody that said,
my mom wanted me to send you an email
to say thank you because she's 71 years
old and she's feeling awesome.
And I was like, all right, cool. Just
grandma's little again. So drone warfare,
Krill oil discipline, discipline, go.
I saw you take some discipline. Go.
Prior to us starting this
podcast, discipline go.
I might have developed a small addiction
to discipline and discipline go. Uh,
it's honestly the first supplement
that I've taken where I'm like, Eh,
we'll see that, that
it, it just works. This,
it works. And, uh, it's, I you,
so I travel a lot. I don't
get a ton of sleep, you know,
the lifestyle we live right
now. We're, we're, we're,
we're moving pretty aggressively and I
have to be in the game, man. I can't, I,
I can't show up and be like, Hey,
I'd love to give you my best today,
but I'm tired. That's not part
of the deal. And, um, you know,
you can go with the frontal assault power
through a method or you can actually
take, something's gonna help you out.
This stuff is legit, man. It is legit.
And yeah, I took it before this,
cause you know what I wanted to be in the
game and how much on the mock train is
the Burke family at this
point? So here's another,
I went to your house and like
open the book and I was like, oh,
this dude's got a problem.
So here's the thing, man,
is every time I think I'm on the train,
I'm like, man, I'm still on the train.
And I'm like, oh. And then the mint,
I'm like still on the mint
and then the peanut butter,
it actually took the strawberry milk to
make me realize what it really means to
be on the MOC train because I, you know,
and I, I keep a little low profile job.
Uh, you know, uh, echoes,
I'm not the key spokesperson
for [inaudible] Bro.
When we got strawberry Mulcair that
has a whole nother level man. Um,
and I was, you know, I did peanut butter
and like Ah, I kind of went back to,
I have not gotten off the strawberry
mold train yet. It is still just, it's,
it's so good and everybody in the house,
nobody wants the other stuff right now.
And I was, you know, I go back to this
stuff cause it's, it's good. I like,
I really liked the other
stuff but strawberry right
now is still at the top of
the list and it hasn't
moved for a while. Yeah.
I finally got off the strawberry
train. Cause you know,
cause I got it before everyone else
and then I was just so deep into it.
And plus I was the, I was on the
warrior kid, Strawberry Mobile.
That's where it started. So I
was already on that. So yeah,
maybe like a week ago
I was having a little,
little lunchtime hitter and I and I
had some peanut butter and so anyways,
hey, if you want to get some extra
protein in your life, check out the milk.
Any of those flavors are really delicious.
And we got warrior kid milk too,
which is awesome for your kids.
It's actually crazy that no one made it.
It's actually crazy that no one made
warrior kid milk before we did because
here, oh, you want your kids to drink
poison? That sounds like a good plan.
No one's feeding their kid poison except
for everyone that's feeding their kid
chocolate milk filled with sugar. No
one thought of it. Cool. I did. Well,
we'll just go as water can
Paulk you'll taste awesome.
Your kids are gonna love it. And
you've got Jocko white tea too.
You can even get the dry Pete tea bags
or you can get into can and you can crack
that open. And by the way, right now,
we're drinking, actually at this time,
the, or I'm drinking the,
the Jocko discipline
go in a can. And it's,
so here's the thing, same thing.
If you are a parent and you
know that [inaudible] exists,
you should not buy anything else because
it's not good for your kids. It's not.
I got the early sample of the go and
a can got to try that a couple about a
month ago. If you, when this
happens and you drink it,
there is no reason to ever
buy a carbonated beverage
or any other type again,
ever. You should not have the seven up.
You should never buy a seven up ever
again. No, you won't buy seven up.
You won't buy a red bull or
you won't buy a coke. You know,
you'll just buy this cause it's actually
good for you and it tastes awesome,
blah, blah, blah. All
right, cool. So that's that.
And also we do have a store
that's called Jocko store.
That is Jocko store.com and there we got
rash guards and tee shirts and hats and
in hoodies. You get some women's
gear too. By the way. My wife,
every article of clothing she now owns
has the origin logo on it like everyone
and now that we're out in the west coast,
the winter deer winter gear here
is a Hoodie. Yeah, that's it. Sure.
And the women's hoodies are lightweight
Hoodie or we are still just regular
hoodies. No lightweight hoodies
yet. When he's still a little,
she doesn't do lightweight and says
she's cold. She puts on the Hoodie.
I'm a lightweight guy now.
I got, I got both hoodies.
I transitioned though like the medium
way or those? The lightweight one. Yup.
Which you were all echo that
put you on the spot. Yeah Bro.
How do you like that? Right in
front of me, he did as he wants to,
he is a valley. He will looking for some
validation that echo turtles. So yeah,
you can get all that stuff. You
can support the podcast Jocko,
store.com represent, what does echo say?
Represent while being on the
path. That's what he says.
He says it in like a um, sort
of a really super dramatic way.
Okay.
If you want to represent, sometimes
echo takes long pauses like I do,
but there's no sensibility to them.
They'll just say if you want to
represent wall, you're on the path.
But Hey, that's my brother. I called
Charles a m we have this podcast,
subscribe to it. It's whatever
you subscribe to. Podcasts,
leave reviews. Where your
kid podcast Dave. Good.
Three more just came out a couple
of weeks ago. Yeah, burn through.
My kids were so fired up because I had
episode 14 on repeat in the car cause
they will listen.
Literally listened to those storied
pot podcasts over and over again.
Even if they'd heard them.
And we just got through three new ones
in the last week and they were fired up
the stories from Uncle Jake.
Okay.
So good. We,
the one we just did it just just today
was the kid had the car and the two other
kids wanted that radio controlled
car, but it was expensive and they,
there's two paths down to getting that
car and one which was a little discipline
with your money, save your money, save
a little bit here, a little bit there.
And at the end you know what you get,
you get the thing that you want and his
other kid and you use an example of ice
cream on Fridays at school for a dollar.
That literally is exactly what my kids
get from realizing said yes and they saw
that little delayed
gratification. Yeah. Kids, kids,
kids understand that man. I know
they're young, but they, these stories,
they make sense to them. They
internalize it, they understand it.
They're not too young to
figure out these life lessons,
the classic parables of life that
every kid, you just wish and,
and I think they get so ingrained with
the kids when they hear these stories,
they're so relatable and they
go, oh yeah, it's, it's like,
it's like embedded in them now. They
understood. They truly understand
would that it that you have to delay
gratification sometimes. For example,
they truly understand that you
have to make the right decisions.
They truly understand that the
world doesn't sound around them.
They truly understand that you have
to work the embeds in their brains.
So check out that warrior kid or your
kid podcast and if you want to help out a
warrior kid, you can go to Irish oaks
ranch.com and Aiden, who's a warrior kid,
he's just working hard,
running a business at age 13
he's making soap with goat milk.
You can get that soap
so you can stay clean.
Youtube channel where echo makes
legit videos in his opinion.
Other people have that opinion as
well. I do. Oh you do? Oh yeah. Oh,
you're an echo Charles. Those
videos are legit supporter big time.
Do you think echo goes overboard
from time to time? Yes, I do.
I absolutely get out of
balance every now and then.
How many explosions
can there be? You know,
Jocko talk where you say, okay,
that was a bit much. Yeah,
nine is over the limit. So there's that.
There's, yeah. If you subscribe
to the Youtube Channel,
then you'll see them pop up and
you're can watch them and you can,
some of them are smaller so you don't
have to listen to a three hour podcast,
which not everyone has time to do.
Understood psychological warfare,
it's got little short excerpts,
not even excerpts there. A
little short statements from me.
If you got a little weakness
that you're trying to overcome,
you can go to iTunes, Google
play MP3. You can get those
and press play when you're
about to take a, I take a hit,
go down the wrong path. Take a step
off the path. Yeah, press play.
Stay on the path. That's a good one.
If you want a visual representative
representation, you can go to flip side,
canvas.com my brother Dakota Meyer,
he's running this business.
He's making art for your wall,
high quality that say all kinds of good
stuff on things like good things like
discipline equals freedom.
So check it out. Flip side,
canvas.com you got on it who's
making all kinds of good stuff.
Check out their go to on it.com/jocko
and check out some of their various
equipment. If you want plain
equipment, you can get it there.
If you are more like Echo Charles and
you want to have little artistic things
and you can get that as well.
Got Some books. Yeah. Yeah.
Another thing that's on repeat in
my house are the warrior kid books,
so yeah, he knows there's,
there's three of them out there way of
the warrior kid and Mark's mission or
your kid three is out there
at where there's a will.
That book has been read
repeatedly. I get to the end,
we go back to the beginning every now
and there'll be a detour back to one of
the other books, one or two,
but right now three is on repeat
into the three kids. Those books are
are legit and even Mikey and
the dragons. Even that book,
even though it's for younger kids,
another book that my kids love,
not just because they
can read it themselves,
but because the actually understand the
message of the story. It's so legit.
Those books. Those books are awesome.
And those books are our must,
not just for the kids, but for the parents
who are reading a man. We've got the,
uh, the discipline equals freedom field
manual. If you want to check that out,
it's one of it's, it's a book that
people take pictures of the book,
like they'd take pictures of the
book. Yeah. And I'll tell you,
let me tell you a little something about
this book. I'll tell you, you know,
have you ever heard me talk
smack about my publisher before?
Your current publisher? My
current publisher? Yeah.
Yeah. So yeah, yeah, yeah.
So occasionally I do that. Here's
one example of me doing that.
So inside when you open
it up, they give the, uh,
they give the credit to the design cover
design and they get like somebody that
works there and I'm sure
they did, they hooked it up.
But like I sent him this
picture and said, okay,
this is what it's going
to look like. So it's a,
but they did do a great job
with it and it came out solid.
It has black pages.
They have to dye the edges
black. It's a black book dude.
It's called discipline of
course. Freedom field manual.
The publisher told me he was the biggest
risk he ever took with publishing a
book. Really? Yeah. He
said, he said, I said,
is this the riskiest book you've ever
cooked? He was, oh my God. Not even close.
Nothing's even close because there's no
preexisting book, anything like that.
So you're doing something completely
outside uncharted territory.
I hope it worked out for him. It worked
out well for them. It worked out well.
It actually worked out awesome and I
appreciate everyone checking that out.
It's a book that you know what you want.
You see the big spike in sales
is toward a graduation time.
People get it for Elliot,
everyone's graduating school.
Oh, here you go. Here's,
here's what you should do now that you're
done with high school and get on the
path. So that's a, the freedom
discipline. It was freedom field manual.
The audio version of that is not
on audible. It's on MP3. So iTunes,
Amazon music, Google play, whatever.
And then extreme ownership. Dude,
the beginning man, a lot of
folks have read it. I know. Um,
so here's the thing about
extreme ownership has to be
read also good for younger
kids. I actually read part of that stuff
to my kids. They get it, but it's not,
it's not. Everything that, and
dichotomy together are art. They have,
they go together. You have to
read them both. Uh, they're,
they're critical and they,
it explains how actually even with
the lessons in that first one,
you can go too far on
any of those principles.
You can go too far and you gotta bring
dichotomy into that understanding of
extreme ownership. Lafe was telling
me maybe like a year ago, he goes,
Yo, I was just rereading
extreme ownership. He goes,
I've been like trying to
fake. He's, he's like, I just,
I was trying to figure out a way to say
something and then I read it and I was
like, oh wait, it's in there. Like the,
the actual answers in there. He's like,
I was trying to recreate a way or craft
a way to say something. He's like, man,
I forgot that I even wrote this section
or whatever. So yeah, check that out.
And what about echelon?
Front echelon front,
the good deal, Dave story continues
because I am, I'm part of that team now.
Uh, the, the lessons, all those
things we just talked about, uh,
not just on this podcast but
in those books, Jocko and, uh,
lave actually put together this company
that I'm a part of that takes all those
leadership principles and we
help companies solve problems.
Every problem is solved
through leadership. Everyone.
And I'm part of a team that is not
just carrying just a good message,
but a message that can actually impact
everybody's life. Business, personal,
every aspect of it. Uh,
obviously you and Lafe, uh,
putting this together came on board with
JP, uh, Flint cocker and Mike Sorelli,
Mike [inaudible], Jason Gardner.
The team has grown. Man,
I'm so stoked to be on this team with
those guys, man. It is, it is legit.
How about you if online,
if online is turned out to be even more
important of a resource than I thought
because one of the hardest
things we have to chat,
one of the hardest challenges we have
is when we leave a company is we want to
stay as connected to them as we can
and look you're not there everyday.
Oh you mean it's not like a rocky movie
or we just get Paul pumped up that
amazingly sometimes takes more training
than just just just the rocky movie.
Yeah. What it takes is reps,
hundreds and thousands
of reps and what he,
if online lets people do
is get reps, rep after rep,
after rep and that resource has proven,
I knew it was going to be important.
I didn't realize how
important it was going to be,
not just to reach folks that
can't spend time with us,
but even once they spend time with us,
what they need to do to reinforce the
things that we're talking about ETF online
is works in both directions. If
we're not working with you know,
factor it's there and if
we are working with you,
they are realizing how important that
is to stay connected to you. Man.
It's legit. And then the muster,
I like listening to you talk about this
stuff. What about the muster muster?
I probably said the word legit too many
times, but I'm going to say it again.
As a, as a leadership conference,
there's nothing like it. You,
you have said every single podcast
the muster is going to sell out.
And yet there are still people that
towards the end of signing up and we put
some ask if they can go. Not
only did the last one sell out,
we got Denver coming
up in September. It's,
it's almost sold out in September
and we're actually looking,
so we've got mustard in
September, uh, coming up in, um,
in Denver on September 19th
20th. We also have Sydney,
December 4th and fifth asked me how close
we are to selling out Sydney through
close.
We're going to sell at Sydney and our
first overseas muster in December 4th and
fifth. Uh, these events. Yeah. Do the
these are, these are the things that put,
these are
things that make the things we talk about.
They make them real, they make them.
So really you can take back from those
two days and have so much to go do for
yourself to make your life
in your company better. Uh,
there is not a better way to truly
understand what it is that we're teaching
than the master.
It is legit from beginning to end and
it is made huge impact on folks lives.
I can't tell you how many emails I get.
I get God only knows what you're getting
of what the muster meant to their life,
to their, to what it
did for, for their life.
They're all the next one
coming up in Denver in Denver.
Go while you're still can go,
you're also going to be close.
And then there's the f Overwatch,
which is where we're taking proven
leaders from special operations and from
combat aviation and we are placing
them into civilian companies that need
leadership. These guys are
tested, they are proven,
they've been in charge,
they've led people,
they've been under stress and pressure.
And now they're looking
for their next career.
Why not have their next
career be with you?
Taking the principles that we talk about
all the time and implementing them into
your organization.
Okay.
Yeah.
F overwatch.com if you want
to get involved with that
and if you want to discuss
any of these topics further, you can
actually find us on the interwebs,
on Twitter, on Instagram
and on Dine Foz in walking.
Dave is at David R. Burke,
B. E. R. K. E. N. I am at jockowillink.
Dave, any closing thoughts?
My closing thoughts is that I'm so stoked
that I'm here right now here on the
west coast and get to
be a part of this man.
Thank you Jack and to all you folks out
there in uniform that are executing the
tactics that we've been talking about
today in order to keep our country free.
Thank you.
And to our police and law enforcement
and firefighters and paramedics and mts
and dispatchers and correctional officers
in border patrol and secret service
and all first responders. You know, I, I,
I've heard a statement that when you
hear an ambulance or you hear a fire,
it's a reminder to you
that you know, you're,
someone's having a worse day than you.
Okay?
It, and that's certainly true, but
let me take it one step further.
Cause I actually don't think
that when I hear that siren,
I think about the people that are
responding, those firefighters,
those paramedics, those police,
and they're going to put
themselves into harms away.
Okay?
That's what I think about
when I hear those sirens.
So for those of you that
do those jobs for a living,
thank you for keeping our homeland
safe and to everyone else out there,
right?
You gotta remember we're at war and you
were at war and maybe not a war in the
classic sense of the word that you're
out there with a weapon and you're
fighting against a uniformed enemy,
but make no mistake, life ran.
I know this might sound harsh, but
life is war. It's a war against time.
It's a war against weakness.
It's a war against the ego.
It's a war against the most base
part of you as a human being.
So as the Marine Corps doctrine says,
actively and aggressively seek it
out, and when the opportunity arrives,
level every ounce of power you can muster,
pushing
beyond the limits of exhaustion
to achieve total victory.
Okay.
And until next time,
this is Jocko and Dave
out.